am start bisschen später als sonst
zwanzig minuten später
ich muss heute mal ausschlafen
normalerweise bin ich ja schon immer irgendwie um halb neun oder so wach
aber
heute nicht
btf
der michael 50.000.000 ist instant am start
das ist das gegenstück
gegenstück zum sub
sub box campen auf youtube
quasi der
twitch chat
camping zelt aufgestellt
hast schon lange gewartet
ja wie gesagt ich bin heute auch bisschen später als sonst
ich muss es grad mal runterstellen
auf 4,9
weil internet in deutschland
wir wissen es ja internet in deutschland ist halt
zack halt
wir können by the way
fällt mir grad mal ein wir können mal wieder
ich muss mal kirby ein bisschen leiser machen
kirby
ah wunderbar
mal wieder zur abwechslung
breitband atlas
mal gucken wie es in deutschland grade so ausschaut
der breitband atlas
oh die haben es geupdatet
das sieht jetzt advanceder aus als das letzte mal
weil der ausbau ist immer noch nicht besser
aber es sieht besser aus
umut
kürpli
nettoasi
auch am start
dauby day
jetzt kommen sie aber alle hier
aber wobei die karte hier ist
eher pippenhans
also gucken wir mal suchen
6 0 3 2 9 frankfurt
verfügbarkeit embits in
prozent
gut
das ist ja auch absolut frankfurt in schon abbauen
wenn hier der kram nicht verfügbar wäre
dann würde ich mir ja auch gelanken machen
aber ich bin auch privat mobil
dsl also wichtig ist
die haben die seite verkackte
man kann das nicht mal richtig filtern
doch hier unten
man kann sagen
leitungsgebunden über 50 embit
guck mal sogar frankfurt
innenstadt wirds da schon
warum kann ich
ach ne
über 100 embit
wieviel haben denn gigabit
in frankfurt
ah
nicht so viele
guckt euch das mal an
so witz
immer noch voll für den arsch
50 embit für jeden
sollten ja übrigens schon
oder so
hast du eigentlich immer noch unity media und telekom leitungen
ne
ich hab nur noch unity media leitungen
ich habs jetzt anders gemacht
guckt euch das mal an
ich hab jetzt unity
unity media
ich hab jetzt
das hier im moment
das da
hab ich jetzt
meine mutter will halt fernsehen gucken
deswegen hab ich das hier geholt
braucht das
wie muss ich dann
berlin tag und nacht oder nein das guckt sie nicht
aber man weiß ja nie so genau
ich guck ja auch benutzt den fernsehen
also für mich hab ich das nicht gekauft
ich bin mir jetzt sicher ist es ale, koluki
oder alle koluki
ich hab jetzt 12 monate abend in folge
auf jeden fall big prime
nein noch nicht mal ein prime, ein richtiger
huge brain sub
wie kommst du aus der abo falle raus
gar nicht, deswegen ist es ja eine abo falle
du musst jetzt jeden monat weiter
sammeln, du hast keine andere
möglichkeit, das geht nicht
oder du musst
dein twitch account löschen
anders ist nicht möglich
so zumindest 10g hab ich jetzt
das stimmt übrigens nicht
das ist gbait, das hier ist das eigentlich
wichtige was man gucken muss
na gut ich kann
ich tu mir manchmal schwierig
bei den zuschauer namen
weil das ist immer rein aus der schreibweise sehr schwierig
zu erkennen wenn man was ausspricht
gbait, also das hier ist das interessante
was man gucken muss
und das stimmt auch nicht so ganz
weil man muss beim bestellen
muss man genau aufpassen
dass man nicht irgendwelche security pakete
2018 war das
50mbz
es war schon von anfang an klar
als die presse erklärung raus kam
war schon klar
dass es nicht funktioniert, aber man kann ja mal
viel behaupten wenn der tag lang ist
wie ist meine lautstärke?
hat schon nichts getan
was man hier gucken muss ist
dass man halt keine komischen security
pakete oder so anhakt und
was ganz
praktisch ist, was ich halt auch noch habe
ist power upload
so power upload ich hab nämlich
440 ab, das kostet aber
ein bisschen mehr und das ist total
total versteckt
man sieht das gar nicht so richtig
ich glaub man muss hier erst
weiß gar nicht wie man hier
power upload
also das kostet nochmal 3€ mehr
also ich bezahl glaube ich dann 63€
oder sowas
irgendwie in dem dreh im monat
ich glaub da ist der fernsehanschluss schon
der kabelanschluss schon mit drinne
so und was ich dann noch gemacht hab
ist, weil
naja
ich bräuchte nicht, aber wir haben halt
immer noch einen festen anschluss mit fester nummer
und das größte problem beim anbieter wechsel
war immer dieses nervige portieren
von der alten festnetz
telefonnummer
meine mutter hängt halt an der festnetz telefonnummer
mir ist das vollkommen wurscht, ich hab glaube ich
das festnetz telefon zweimal
im jahr verwendet oder so
und das einmal um im krankenhaus anzurufen
hab ich ja
auf twitter geschrieben, ist ja schon
ein paar monate her jetzt
und deswegen bin ich
hab ich meine rufnummer
importieren lassen
zu easybell, das ist ein voib anbieter
der hat
ähm
nein nein nein, nur telefon
nur telefon, ich brauch nur telefon
nur telefon
wo ist es denn
ich brauch nicht internet und telefon
ich brauch
nur telefon
genau, und das kostet 2,90 im monat
das sind zwar nochmal 3 euro mehr
im endeffekt, aber
man hat nie wieder
diesen nervigen
festnetz portierungskram
also sprich, ich hab jetzt zwar
triple play
mit telefon von unity media, aber die festnetz nummer
liegt nicht bei unity media, die liegt
für 3 euro bei easybell, einfach dass ich
morgen sagen könnte, unity media
kein bock mehr auf euch, ich geh woanders hin
doch fax kann das auch
fax kann das auch
aber ich glaube ich habe
vor 10 jahre
so mein letztes fax geschickt
und das hab ich auch von der arbeit
aus gemacht, und zwar war das
an, ne das ist nicht ganz 10 jahre her
an ein telekom
in cassoladen, die gesagt haben
ich hätte nen telefonanschluss in heiligenhafen
ich war mein leben
ich weiß gar nicht wo heiligenhafen liegt
ich hab nen brief gekriegt von
der telekom, also von so einem telekom
in cassoladen, ich soll ihnen jetzt
500 euro oder sowas bezahlen
weil ich nen telefonanschluss in heiligenhafen
hab, da hab ich mir gedacht
what
wie kommt ihr auf die idee
und dann haben sie mir ne telefonrechnung geschickt
die sind ja eigentlich verpflichtet
sprich so in cassoladen
musst ihr beweisen, dass die forderung
berechtigt ist, das machen die nicht, die operieren
ja auch teilweise so ein bisschen
in einer rechtlichen grau zone
und
die haben dann geschrieben, ja hier
wir kriegen 500 euro von uns
was ist mit euch los warum
ja telefonanschluss in heiligenhafen
und die telekom hat auch gesagt, ja ja ist berechtigt
ist berechtigt, was soll die telekom auch sonst sagen
dumm schwätzer
und ich mein ich war seitdem irgendwie 5 jahre nicht mehr bei der telekom
so
und
dann habe ich mir so
in caso widerspruch
drunter geladen und habe mir das mal durchgelesen
und die sache ist die
die sind
die sind nicht nur verpflichtet
die mitzuteilen
auf welcher grundlage sie ihre forderung stellen
nein die war nicht bei mir zuhause
dann ist die polizei gerufen, wenn die bei mir da
zuhause gehen
die sind nicht nur verpflichtet
die mitzuteilen, auf welcher
grundlage sie ihre forderung stellen
nein, die sind sogar theoretisch
dazu verpflichtet, die das unaufgefordert
mitzuteilen
also es darf eigentlich gar nicht sein
dass du 5 mal den antworten musst
und nach dem motto jetzt erzähl doch mal
warum wollt ihr eigentlich was
für mir, das müssen die eigentlich
wohlgemerkt, müssen die das
ohne rückfrage machen
ohne dass du irgendwas sagen musst
haben sie nicht, mal ganz davon abgesehen
ich hab dann nur noch ein 2.
fax zurückgeschrieben so nach dem motto
durch das
ich war noch nie ein heiliger affen
ich muss mir jetzt nicht den vertrag zeigen
den ich unterschrieben hab, wenn ich den
weiteren schriftverkehr lehne
lehn ich ab
danach kam auch nichts mehr
die konnten mir
die konnten mir nicht
beweisen, wie ich angeblich
zu einem telefonanschluss in
heiligenhafen gekommen bin, ich mein ich war in meinem leben
noch nicht in heiligenhafen, ich hab keine ahnung was die von mir wollen
ich weiß gar nicht wo, wo ist das eigentlich?
wo ist das, ostsee, nordsee
an der grenze zu dänemark
wo ist das
ostsee
da ist es
warum sollte ich da
einen telefonanschluss gebucht haben
haha
what the fuck
krass war doch
das ist ja fast schon in dänemark
das ist so quasi an der
brücke zu dänemark
gut zumindest da
hab ich angeblich einen telefonanschluss
500 euro
und sie haben ja
auf das erste fax haben sie geantwortet mit
einer telefonrechnung
so nach dem motto wir begründen
unsere forderung in der rechnung die wir irgendwann mal gestellt
haben
und auf
der telefonrechnung stand halt
irgendeine adresse drauf in heiligenhafen
wo ich keine ahnung von hatte was es ist
und halt mein name, die sache ist jetzt halt nur die
wie kommt die telekom
das hab ich bis heute nicht raus gekriegt
wie kommt die telekom drauf
dass
ich dort oben einen anschluss abgeschlossen
habe
habe ich es nicht, vollkommener schwachsinn
sag mal so
mein vorname nachname kombination
ist nicht so
es ist jetzt nicht max müller oder so
es ist schon recht
recht selten
also ich vermute mal
die haben alle maximilians mit dem passenden nachname
in deutschland irgendwie angeschrieben
in der hoffnung einer bezahlt den scheiß
ich mein ich hab es nicht abgeschlossen
ganz schön weit weg von frankfurt
big brain sub
naja
wie dem auch sei
das war nicht der grund warum ich
zur telekom gewechselt habe, aber die kombination habe ich jetzt
ich hab jetzt nur noch unity media
440 ab
und meine festnetznummer hab ich
hier zu easybell, dass ich einfacher
Einfacher anbieter wechseln kann das war's
Max musterfrau genau
Heute ist es überhaupt kein keine schande mehr ja heute ist das
Ich kann heute muss der mann und morgen muss der frau sein das ist überhaupt kein problem
So ich habe irgendwas übersehen im chat gerade vorhand
Offer unity media kriegt seine notes mal in den griff im upload also ich muss sagen das ist aber immer sehr regional
sehr regional unterschiedlich
ich muss sagen dass
das bei mir ohne probleme funktioniert ich habe überhaupt keine wirklich gar keine schmerzen mit unity media weder am wochenende noch an
Irgendwie abenden oder abends am wochenende oder irgendwelche sachen das funktioniert alles wunderbar
Wir hatten ja auch hier im upload
probleme bevor ich unity media umgestellt habe
Aber unity media hat mich ja beschissen das habe ich weiß nicht ob ich dir schon erzählt habe also unity media hat mich ja beschissen
insofern dass ich unity media gesagt habe
Ich würde gern umsteigen aber nur nur wenn ich kein ds light bekomme
Das war die vordere voraussetzung das haben die mir überall garantiert das haben die mir ein paar twitter garantiert per private message überall
per alles ja der dieser kundendings wie heißt das
kunden bindungs
rückdings hotline service alle alle alle haben sie mir das garantiert und ich habe das ja auch schriftlich als pm auf
also schriftlich in anführungsstrichen ja also das haben die mir alle garantiert ich kriege kein ds light
so anschluss wurde umgestellt
und es hat erst mal eine weile gedauert bis das ganze dann gelieft nachdem ich das dsl modem angeschlossen habe also sprich
Das das das konfiguriert sich dann erst mal so eine halbe stunde rum und dann nach hatte ich auch kein ds light alles gut
So und irgendwie zwei wochen später da haben wir doch noch gestreamt könnt ihr euch dran erinnern da haben wir glaube ich sogar live gestreamt
Habe ich dann unity media habe ich habe ich dann ich dachte irgendwie ist ja es backt backt rum was ist für scheiß
und habe ich geguckt da hatte ich auf einmal ds light
so twitter support angeschrieben ich kann euch generell nur empfehlen schreibt bei unity media unter telekom und sonst was
flamet öffentlich auf twitter und und und
erwähnt den support die sind immer ziemlich zackig und dadurch dass es direkt öffentlich ist haben die auch immer ein gewisses interesse dran die sachen schnell zu lösen
also twitter support ist das beste was ihr machen könnt wenn ihr problem mit eurem telefonanbieter habt
so und dann haben die mir doch geschrieben so nach dem motto ja sie wären sie wären gezwungen so nach dem motto das umzustellen
ich sag mal ihr habt mir das garantiert dass es nicht umgestellt wird sonst hätte ich das überhaupt nicht umgestellt das hätte ich das überhaupt nicht gemacht
so und dann haben sie gesagt ah ja da ist was schief gelaufen das ist sinngemäß da ist was schief gelaufen doch michael das bringt auch was mit null follower
nein das bringt auch was mit null follower allein schon weil du die erwähnt
allein schon weil du die erwähnt und dein problem direkt in zusammenhang mit entsteht die sind auch nicht so gut
versteht die sind die sind schnell wenn es danach geht die sind wirklich zackig du brauchst kein 20 oder 25.000 follower das reicht
so zumindest haben sie irgendwie irgendwie schief gelaufen oder sowas in der richtung haben sie geschrieben
diese option die ich haben möchte gebe es nur mit in verbindung mit power upload aber dann wäre es auch ein richtiger dual stack
also dann wäre es auch richtig ipv4 und richtig ipv6 und nicht ipv4 only also das ist ja viel besser das will ich haben
und glücklicherweise habe ich schon längst power upload dabei gebucht und das hat sie wahrscheinlich vorher nicht gecheckt auf twitter
weil die wollte mir halt noch mal zusätzlich power upload verkaufen aber ich hatte ja schon längst power upload gebucht das hatte ich glaube ich nicht gesehen
aber das machen wir und zum glück habe ich ja schon power upload gebucht bezahle ich schon so und da guckt sie nach und dann schreibt sie nur noch so zurück
ja ich habe das jetzt eingebucht und sollte in nächster zeit aktiv werden und siehe da das war auch aktiv ich hatte danach komplett echt dual stack
ipv4 ipv6 aber auf der nächsten rechnung habe ich festgestellt die rechnen mir jetzt ein doppelt power upload ab
ich habe das wusste gar nicht dass man das überhaupt ankreuzen kann bei dem im system alter die haben mich so krass jibay was heißt jibay die haben mich beschissen
wenn man es genau nimmt wenn man es genau nimmt haben die mich beschissen also ich bezahle jetzt nicht die 63 euro damit sondern die 66 euro mit power
weil ich power upload ja irgendwie doppelt habe aber wohlgemerkt ich habe nicht doppelt ein power upload also ich habe keine 80mbit upload ich habe bloß 40mbit upload
aber ich habe jetzt echt ein dual stack also im prinzip heißt das unterm strich ich bezahle jetzt 3 euro im monat mehr für echt dual stack und ganz ehrlich so rein mal unterm strich
davon abgesehen dass sie mich beschissen haben und mal anders kann man das nicht ausdrücken die haben mich halt richtig beschissen
ne büsnungsleitung ist nicht billiger definitiv auf keinen fall aber ich habe mich schon ausgerechnet hätte ich gemacht ist deutlich teurer vor allem wenn du fernseher noch dabei willst
unterm strich bezahle ich 3 euro im monat für einen echten dual stack anschluss so ganz unterm strich würde ich sagen das ist ok bin ich bereit dafür das zu bezahlen
doobie day 5 monate huge sub big brain big prime sub so jetzt habe ich euch die untimer story nochmal erzählt weil die haben mich alle heftig debated aber business guckt mal wie die anbindung an der kleierstraße in frankfurt die anbindung aussieht
ich kenne die kleierstraße zufällig in frankfurt da war früher unser rechenzentrum die anbindung in der kleierstraße in frankfurt sollte eigentlich ziemlich gut sein da gibt es viele rz anbieter mit mehreren gigabit uplink also ich meine das ist zwar nicht telekom und auch nicht unity media aber die infrastruktur sollte da sein dass sich telekom und unity media relativ easy anstöpseln können um hohe bandbreiten zu liefern
was how to save all your tabs achja leute übrigens ich hab angefangen ein video aufzunehmen für youtube jetzt ernsthaft kein witz wollte ich eigentlich heute morgen fertig machen aber ich hab mir gedacht nee ich muss erst mal stream anmachen ist schon so spät
und jetzt wirklich ohne scheiß weil ich hab so ein paar chrome geschichten die mir aufgefallen sind die kaum jemand kennt und die richtig praktisch sind deswegen werde ich mal so ein richtig krasses clickbait video machen so nach dem motto 5 chrome tips die euer leben verändern oder irgendwie sowas in der richtung
so ich könnte ich könnte euch jetzt schon spoilern soll ich euch schon mal spoilern was das für was das für tips sind
oh dubi dave hat ein abo verschenkt an klarni dankeschön
komm ich spoilere euch schon mal ich erkläre euch ich spoilere euch schon mal was das für tips sind und zwar da muss ich erstmal mein notizprogramm aufmachen weil sonst denke ich da gar nicht dran
also ihr wisst ja wenn ich mir notizen gemacht hab dann wirds hier serious business also wir machen jetzt hier mal ein chrome auf irgendwie ein paar tabs google youtube sonst war es vollkommen egal youtube wir machen einfach youtube jetzt noch ein paar mal auf so wunderbar
so also erster tip den viele leute nicht kennen ist wenn ihr ähm wechselt so zu firefox wenn google den adblock schrittstelle deaktiviert also sollte sollte wirklich ich wusste gar nicht dass das ich wusste gar nicht dass das überhaupt ein ding ist dass das google vorhat ja
ist das so möchte möchte google das deaktivieren ja
wie kommst du da drauf hab ich überhaupt nichts von mitgekriegt aber sollte google auf heise echt du kannst mir mal den link schicken falls du es findest also sollte google das ernsthaft machen dass in chrome kein adblocker mehr möglich ist die würden sich so krass ins eigene also die würden sich richtig ins eigene fleisch schneiden
die werden sich so ins eigene fleisch schneiden wenn kein adblock mehr funktioniert das ist ja eins der großen vorteil noch der desktop browser dass du halt ohne eingeschränkt machen kannst oder fast ohne einschränkung machen kannst was du willst
also sollten die das ach michael war ja eine güde ey pp hens ne hier ähm so und sollte google das machen dann werde ich werde ich kein chroma verwenden das sehe ich nicht ein allerdings verwende ich ja chromium und chromium könnte ich mir vorstellen die lassen die schrittstelle einfach drinnen
ähm aber ansonsten verwende ich einfach wieder firefox extreme nerd vier monate dankeschön ajaja so zumindest ich wollte euch jetzt hier fünf krassen chrome hacks zeigen und zwar das erste ist ähm wenn ihr paar tabs auf habt und wollt alle tabs gleichzeitig refreshen
das kennt kaum jemand die meisten Leute machen dann sowas ich will alle meine tabs refreshen so dabei dabei geht das viel einfacher und jetzt kommt trick 17 du kannst einfach die tabs die du äh refreshen willst kannst du markieren so und dann drückst du f5 und dann reloaden alle tabs
das ist big brain oder gabs du das kanntet ihr noch nicht alle man kann übrigens auch selektiv machen man kann auch sagen den tab den tab und den tab drück der f5 bamm alles da das ist unglaublich praktisch vor allem wenn man irgendwelche webseiten testen will
ähm so nach dem motto wie viele browser connections verkraftet mein backend oder sowas ihr wolltet noch nie alle tabs refreshen ich schon das funktioniert das ist build in es gibt ein paar addons die das können
äh einfach shift shift gedrückt halt markieren oder oder mit steuerung einfach die tabs die man die man äh refreshen will auswählen es kann sein dass es tasten kombination gibt aber hier kann man das selektiv machen ähm und das kennt kaum jemand das ist richtig big brain ja ajaja und ähm
warum kann ich mein dokument nicht arbeiten
so das nächste ist ähm was auch geil ist wie oft hattet ihr hattet ihr es schon dass ihr äh den den rechner ausschalten wolltet beziehungsweise chrome beenden den account wechsel oder sonst was und ihr wolltet an der gleichen stelle weitermachen wo ihr vorher aufgehört habt
das funktioniert teilweise ähm wenn man wenn man einfach den browser zumacht und äh sagt dann hier restore last tabs und sowas das funktioniert manchmal äh toxy drei monate dankeschön big brain sub
ähm das funktioniert manchmal allerdings spätestens wenn man mehrere browser fenster auf hat ähm oder auch wenn man ähm die nicht in der richtigen reinfolge beendet dann funktioniert das nicht richtig was man machen kann ist auch richtig big brain ich weiß jetzt gar nicht mehr genau wie es funktioniert man kann hier oben hinklicken rechts klicken und sagen bookmark all tabs und das mache ich jedes mal jetzt ähm jedes mal wenn ich den stream beende oh der hype train läuft leute der twitch
train ist am start auf auf lasst euch das geld aus der tasche ziehen leute eats eats money eats live für twitch und natürlich für mich auch so das mache ich jetzt nämlich immer am ende äh von der stream äh session wenn ich nicht alle videos durchgekriegt hab die wir gucken wollten dann gehe ich hier einfach hin sag äh bookmark big bookmark all tabs und da legt ihr mir den ordner an wo die letzte session alle alle alle noch geöffneten äh tabs aus der letzten session drin sind
dafür gibt es addons aber wozu soll ich addons installieren wenn da kram schon mit dabei ist extrem not die hydra ist am start so ähm das nächste ist das habe ich euch schon gezeigt dass man äh hier
dass man ich weiß gar nicht ob das in chrome geht geht das überhaupt in chrome kann man in chrome master passport vergeben wenn es nicht geht ist der tipp hinfällig ich dachte das geht weil es geht auch nur weil in firefox geht das weiß gar nicht ob das in chrome funktioniert
ach das hat gerade chrome sowas google does not have a master password ok dann könnt ihr diesen tipp schon mal streichen äh der nächste tipp den ich mir aufgeschrieben hab ist dark mode man kann den chrome relativ easy wenn man hier die äh das hier das hier editiert kann man äh chrome dark mode command switch
oh guck mal das geht auch anders mittlerweile ach ne das ist android was oh ne guck mal man kann das man kann das direkt mittlerweile an machen oder stufe 1 halb 2 abgeschlossen huge
aber muss sagen seit Amazon twitch übernommen hat ist da ist das sub das sub und bit abeid ist schon angesagt
Ach, das funktioniert, das wusste ich gar nicht, dass man das direkt einstellen kann.
Was?
Enter Settings Menu, choose personalize.
Man kann dem Ding nämlich auch einen, man kann dem Ding nämlich auch einen Parameter
hinten dran hängen, hier am starten.
Was?
Äh, choose Settings Menü und dann personalization, wo ist das überhaupt?
Personal, ich wisse, ich weiß gar nicht wo das ist, Windows Settings, ach muss ich doch
hier unten hin.
Was?
Das ist, ich bin da, ich bin da zu doof für, ich würde das jetzt über den Kommandozeilen
Switch machen.
Den neuen Edge haben wir schon ausprobiert, ja.
Was auch immer, das wäre Tipp Nummer 4, ich habe da nachgeguckt wie es funktioniert.
Ach direkt in den Windows Settings, das will ich nicht, ich will nur Chrome, ich will nur
Chrome einstellen und das geht relativ easy, indem man die, das hier editiert und ich glaube
Force Dark Mode oder sowas anhängt.
Und dann startet Chrome immer im Dark Mode.
Über die Chrome Flex geht es auch, hier, das kann man ändern, kann man Force Dark Mode
hinten dran machen, ups und jetzt wenn man das startet, was wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht
funktioniert, äh, weil ich den, weil ich die Session schon auf habe, dann startet er
im Dark Mode und man braucht keinen Dark Mode Reader oder irgendwelche komischen Dinger
mehr dazu.
So und der letzte Tipp, den ich mir aufgeschrieben habe, den lustigerweise viele Leute nicht
wissen, ich könnte ohne eigentlich gar nicht mehr browsen, muss ich ehrlich sagen, aber
ich wurde auch schon im Stream total oft gefragt wie das funktioniert, ne, also zum Beispiel
ihr seid irgendwie auf Reddit und lest irgendwie was, oh ihr lest hier irgendwas auf PC Masterrace,
oh, so das da, lest ihr gerade, so und ihr verklickt euch, ihr macht das aus Versehen
zu oder ihr schließt den Tab aus Versehen, ich habe so oft gesehen, was die Leute dann
machen ist, sie gehen wieder auf Reddit, machen PC Masterrace und suchen den Thread, den ihr
aufhört, manche gehen in die History, manche gehen in die History und gucken, äh, was habe
ich jetzt zuletzt auf gehabt, das ist ganz einfach, ihr müsst einfach Shift, Steuerung,
T drücken und das öffnet den letzten geschlossenen Tab und dann davor den geschlossenen Tab,
ich frage mich warum das so viele Leute noch nicht mitgekriegt haben, weil ich hab das
schon total oft erlebt, was, wie hast du das jetzt gemacht, wie hast du den letzten Tab
aufgemacht, ähm, und dann alle immer ganz furchtbar begeistert, also ja, Shift, Steuerung,
T, siehst du mal, ich sag ja Chat, jetzt geht es in Firefox auch, ich hätte ein paar Varianten
das zu machen, aber Steuerung, Shift, T ist der beste, woher soll man das kennen, einfach
wissen, ja Steuerung, Shift, W ist das, ist ein bisschen doof, ja, doch das, ja, Murdoch,
das funktioniert teilweise, leider ist das bei Chrome relativ inkonsistent, dass es auch
funktioniert, nachdem du den Browser geschlossen hast, weil, wenn du, also es funktioniert,
wenn du den hier schließt und es ist noch einer auf, wenn du ihn komplett schließt,
dann kann es sein, dass es funktioniert, manchmal funktioniert es nicht, ich hab es noch nicht
genau verstanden, beim Firefox ist es in dem Fall tatsächlich besser, weil der Firefox
hat hier Restore Previous Session und man ist sofort am Start, das ist dem Firefox besser
gemacht.
Jetzt brauchst du das Video auch nicht mehr rauszuhauen, warum nicht, hier gucken 200
Leute zu, auf YouTube gucken 30 Billionen Leute zu, Restore Previous Session gibt es auch
beim Chrome, wo soll es das geben, noch nie gesehen bei Chrome, Stonks, genau, ja irgendwie
walde ich jetzt auch, so siehts aus, ja, jetzt haben wir hier Huge Firefox Tricks uns angeguckt,
du hast ein Level 1 Hype Train Emote erhalten, nice, das beste, also ich find ja die ganzen
Unlock Emotes bei Twitch meistens nicht gut, eins find ich aber richtig cool und zwar
ist es ein Copper Pride Give Energy Emote, das hätt ich gerne, aber man kann es ja leider
nicht selektiv unlocken, Give, Please, Twitch, das da, das Emote als Copper Pride Emote,
das hätt ich gern, aber das hab ich noch nicht, konnte ich noch nicht unlocken, wolltest
du dir nicht einen Ryzen holen, doch wollte ich, aber ich hab mich zusammen gerissen,
ich hab mir gedacht, man 8700K übertaktet, mit immer noch einem der besten Grafikkarten,
die es gibt, ist eine Kombination, die man nicht upgraden muss, deswegen hab ich mich
nochmal zurückgehalten und ich warte jetzt erst, bis das ganze CPU technisch ein bisschen
weiter ist, ja, der einzige Grund warum ich mir einen Ryzen geholt hätte, also ein 16
Kerner wäre halt wirklich, ich hab mir einen 16 Kerner geholt und gleich 64G RAM, weil's
billig ist, einfach für noch mehr VMs und noch mehr Zeugs auf dem Desktop, aber brauchen
tue ich's nicht, brauen brauen tue ich's nicht, und es ist ja, ich hab letztens eine schöne
Grafik gesehen, CPU, Speed, Year, ja, so das hier, das hier ist eigentlich ganz gut, weil,
brauen brauen, was halbwegs aktuell ist, Single Thread, das stimmt nicht, zumindest mittlerweile
ist es so, ich weiß gar nicht in welchem, haben wir den Talk nicht zusammen geguckt,
in irgendeinem Talk hab ich gesehen, und zwar, dass wir mittlerweile von quasi alle zwei
Jahre doppelt so viel, oder halt pro Jahr 52% und hier, guck mal, hier sind wir noch
bei 21% pro Jahr, wir sind mittlerweile bei 3,5% Geschwindigkeitszuwachs im Jahr, CPU,
also Single Thread, weil man kann ja schlecht 6 Kern CPUs mit 16 Kern CPUs vergleichen,
wir sind bei 3,5% Geschwindigkeitszuwachs im Jahr mittlerweile, das ist schon ganz schön
zurückgegangen, und wenn man halt nicht mehr Kerne braucht, wie gesagt, ich hab ja 6 Kerne,
und wenn man halt nicht mehr braucht, oder, also nicht zwingend, irgendwie, ja, das hier,
da, das geht schon in die richtige Richtung, also nicht unbedingt nötig hat, dann ist
halt die Sache, es dauert eine ganze Weile heutzutage, bis eine High-End-CPU wirklich
outdated ist, überlegt euch mal, wenn man sich jetzt eine High-End-CPU kauft, die ist
... da kommt die Raucher-Lunge durch, ja, auch wenn ich noch nie eine Zigarette geraubt
hab, wenn man sich überlegt, man kauft jetzt eine High-End-CPU, und mit 3,5% Zuwachs pro
Jahr, wenn man sich die Benchmarks anguckt, wenn ich mir jetzt eine High-End-CPU kauf,
also quasi 3 Jahre, 2,5, 3 Jahre nachdem ich mir eine High-End-CPU vor 3 Jahren gekauft
hab, dann ist Single-Core-Performance zwischen einem Ryzen 3950X und einem 8700K, es ist
kein Unterschied, der 8700K ist, wenn man ihn übertaktet, sogar mindestens genauso
schnell, wenn nicht schneller, also da ist kein Unterschied, deswegen CPU-Upgraden,
wenn man sich einmal eine High-End-CPU in den letzten Jahren gekauft hat, das hält
lange, das hält lange, wo man sich halt jetzt drüber freuen kann, also Leute, die gerne
neue Hardware kaufen, wie ich, die sich drüber freuen, ich freu mich über die neue Konsolengeneration,
ich freu mich aus einem Grund über die neue Konsolengeneration, nicht weil ich sie mir
bei Release kaufen werde, weil diesmal, diesmal werd ich mir definitiv nicht die neue Konsolen,
na wobei, ihr kennt mich Leute, ihr kennt mich, aber ich sag's jetzt einfach mal, ich werde
mir dieses Jahr definitiv nicht, bis ich sie mir dann doch kaufe, die neue Konsolengeneration
kaufen zu Release, weil ich hab mir die letzte Konsolengeneration zu Release gekauft, und
ich hatte sie ein paar Stunden an, nicht wirklich viel, aber warum ich mich auf die neue Konsolengeneration
freue ist, weil's ordentlich viele CPUs gibt, äh, weil's ordentlich viele neue CPUkerne
gibt, und ähm, weil die jetzt auch mal ordentliche, wieder mal zu Release ordentliche Geschwindigkeit
haben, was definitiv auch Auswirkungen auf PC-Spiele haben wird, und wahrscheinlich das
Ganze wieder mal ein bisschen voranbringt, und dann, wenn das so wirklich mal eingeschlagen
ist, vielleicht in zwei Jahren oder so, dieses Jahr kommt das raus, dann in zwei Jahren ist
es soweit, dass das durch die Bank weg durchgesetzt hat, dann kaufe ich mir einen neuen Rechner,
so lang tut's man 8700k mit 1080ti, und vielleicht mach ich ja bis dahin YouTube-Videos, oder
ich hab bis dahin so den huge big Brain-Stream, dass mir Nvidia wieder eine Grafikkarte sponsert,
wenn nicht, kaufe ich mir dann halt eine 5080ti oder so, was auch immer in zwei Jahren aktuell
ist, bei der Geschwindigkeit, wie Nvidia neue Sachen released, ist in zwei Jahren eine äh,
drei, okay, die, die, die, die, die Benahme muss geändert werden, in zwei Jahren hat Nvidia
dann eine 3581ti oder so was, ähm, tja, so sieht's aus, so, ich hab jetzt ein paar Fragen
übersehen, bevor wir anfangen YouTube zu gucken, weil wenn ihr Fragen habt, ihr müsst
unbedingt Ed Wubblos schreiben, weil der Chat ist halt immer recht viel los, und wenn ich
hier so im Gedanken am erzählen bin wir testen den ist das jebait das video ist das jebait ich
habe schon paar videos von ihm angemacht und dann ging es gar nicht so richtig darum das jebait das
video bestimmt jebait der mich dreimal verarscht hat mit videotitel gucke ich mir dann mal an
ey max kennst du dich mit cupanates aus falls ja kannst du das mal erklären ab ich bin nicht
so der großartig cupanates experte wir haben wir haben cupanates im einsatz bei uns ein bisschen
die grundlagen wie man irgendwelche pots startet kann ich ich würde nicht sagen dass ich jetzt
super krasse cupanates pro bin das steht übrigens bei mir auch schon seit langer zeit mal auf dem
plan dass ich meine dass ich mir den raspberry pi einfach nur weil es geht ich will ihn für
nichts benutzen muss ich gleich dazu sagen den raspberry pi cupanates cluster bauen will einfach
nur ein bisschen rum zu basteln damit den verwende ich aber für nix also ich kann ja aber erklären
was ich kann jetzt zumindest in meinen worten versuchen zu erklären was das ganze ist cupanates
ist im prinzip nichts anderes und nichts anderes ist ein ganz schön großer ganz schön großer
umfeld in dem fall als ein verwaltungstool für container ich glaube wie nennen sie sich selbst
container was orchestrierung was auch immer das ist relativ nicht sagen wenn man wenn man in
diesem bereich nichts zu tun hat es ist ein verwaltungstool für container ein cluster
verwaltung ja ein cluster verwaltungstool für liegungscontainer was dich unter anderem relativ
einfach die anzahl der container skalieren lässt das ist ja so der große der große pluspunkt von
cupanates also sprich du kannst zum beispiel du betreibst du betreibst cs go skin seite und
du weißt am wochenende ist ein großes major das heißt es ist damit zu rechnen dass am wochenende
die skinverkäufe sich verzehnfachen und deine seite ist so minimal gerade ausgelegt dass sie
gerade so den daily traffic abfackeln kann was für dich natürlich auch gut ist weil ressourcen
die du nicht brauchst musst du auch nicht bezahlen also sprich du hast es natürlich nicht bei dir
daheim laufen du hast es in irgendeinem rechenzentrum oder vielleicht in azure in irgendeiner cloud wo
auch immer hast du deine cs go skin dealer seite laufen und du weißt am wochenende ist ein major
und dann kannst du mit cupanates relativ einfach darauf reagieren wenn es dann doch der fall sein
sollte dass alle leute auf einmal anfangen deine skins skins zu zu dealen und zu train weil in
den major turnier war oder neue skin packs oder was auch immer rauskommen dann kannst du relativ
einfach deine frontend server verdreifachen das geht mit cupanates total einfach das ist ein
kommando zahlen befehl und du hast auf einen start start 10 container 50 container natürlich muss die die hardware
unten drunter deswegen ist serverless die größte größte jebait password überhaupt den es zurzeit
gibt die hardware und drunter muss es natürlich hergeben und das schöne an cupanates ist dass du
halt mehrere host also mehrere physische pette kisten quasi verwalten kannst und da drüber deine
container infrastruktur scalen kannst das ist so der das ding was cupanates letztendlich ausmacht
deswegen wenn man passwort mäßig unterwegs ist nennt sich das ganze auch hyperscaler weil weil
geil ja weil es sich gut anhört so und serverless ist ja so ein aktuelles password trend trend wort
serverless ist der größte das größte jebait wort ever serverless ist absolut nicht serverless
serverless ist nicht bei dir ja also der server ist nicht bei dir aber das ist absolut totaler
blödsinn dass das also wer ich weiß nicht welcher welcher big brain bvl mensch auf die bezeichnung
serverless gekommen ist kommt mal die haben sogar eine erklärung dafür in which cloud provider runs
der server ok könnte mir jetzt mal erklären wo das serverless ist der server ist einfach woanders
genauso das ist ja auch immer alle so wenn sie sich erzählen ja wir sind jetzt in der cloud und
sonst was und im prinzip nimmt man einfach seine offline architektur und baut sie in der cloud mit
vm nach was auch totaler schwachsinn ist was mit cloud nichts zu tun hat aber sich alle voll geil
finden weil sie jetzt in der cloud sind es muss es muss einem auch klar sein dass die cloud auch
nur stink normale computer sind die halt nicht bei dir stehen genau easy killer natürlich kann
das dort effizienter betrieben werden dort wo das betrieben wird die haben natürlich auch gewisses
know-how dafür das ist es hat vorteile die man nicht abstreiten kann das ist es kann günstiger
sein in der regel ist es aber nicht günstiger oder nicht wirklich großartiger unterschied eher
teurer eher teurer als wenn man das lokal laufen lässt du hast vorteile ja natürlich das ist
deutlich einfacher verfügbar zu machen es ist deutlich einfacher da hohe verfügbarkeits zahlen
an sich zwar das ist alles kein ding aber sich jetzt quasi die realität so der realität zu
verweigern so nach dem motto cloud ist cloud und serverless ist serverless ist halt auch blödsinn
das ist halt nicht serverless dran was hältst du eigentlich von virtuellen server von gaming
zwecke für gaming server spricht nichts dagegen man kann ja ohne problem warum warum sollte ich
eine minecraft warum sollte die minecraftserver besser auf echte hardware laufen als in dem
container laufen als in der echten vm laufen es macht keinen unterschied solange es läuft läuft
und solange genug cpu drinne ist ist genug cpu drinne und es läuft was sagst du eigentlich dazu
dass docker ihr enterprise geschäft verkauft haben ich kann es nicht verstehen ich kann nicht
verstehen wie ist docker docker ink heißen die oder also ist kein druckehersteller aber die ja
ich mir ist es ein vollkommenes rätsel wie ist docker als also quasi der linux container trendsetter
wie es docker nicht geschafft hat großartig profitabel zu sein ich habe keine ahnung was
sie da gemacht haben und dadurch dass docker den kram verkauft sehe ich sehe ich auch so ein bisschen
so ein bisschen die die gefahr darin dass docker zunehmend an bedeutung verliert wohlgemerkt nicht
linux container linux container hat ja auch mit docker nichts zu tun docker ist ein frontend für
linux container lxc ist die eigentliche linux kernel container geschichte nennst du lxc es gibt
ein lxc frontend was ich auch lxc nennt weil die sich gedacht haben benahmung ist gut zur um die
ganze sache noch komplexer zu machen gibt es noch lxd das ist was von den ubuntu leuten weil die
sich auch gedacht haben nach lxc kommt lxd und die benahmung ist natürlich eh schon toll weil
lxc schon doppeldeutig ist machen wir jetzt noch lxd dass das ganze noch klarer wird aber lxc sind
linux linux container und docker ist im prinzip auch nur ein frontend für allerdings machen ja
viele lxc plus plus gibt es bestimmt auch noch es gibt potman als alternative von club redhead es
gibt jede menge in letzten jahren letzten zwei drei jahren sind jede menge alternative docker
implementierung beziehungsweise jede menge alternative container management geschichten
entstanden so dass gerade jetzt wenn docker sich da ein bisschen weiter zurück zieht docker schon
an bedeutung verlieren könnte wobei ich nicht hoffen werde nicht hoffen ich hoffe weil ich
habe mich jetzt ziemlich dran gewöhnt und es macht genau das was man will also ich fände es
eigentlich ganz gut wenn docker docker bleibt und nicht die xd software von microsoft red hat
mikro wenn haben wir da noch was auch immer da irgendwie am start ist und sie haben es halt nie
geschafft was orchestrierungs mäßiges anzubieten die hatten glaube ich docker wie ist das wie ist
das von docker fleet war das war das swarm swarm oder swarm ist das glaube ich von docker oder
oder fliegt ich kann mir das immer swarm ja das wurde halt auch gladenlos abgehängt von kubernetes
also das stimmt was der noob runner schreibt das ist halt vorbei so jetzt haben wir noch ein paar
questions kennst du docker kraft da kann man docker in minecraft verwalten ne kenne ich nicht aber
minecraft server in docker laufen zu lassen klingt für mich eh schon nicht sonderlich kompliziert
ich meine das ist das ist ein ziemlich selbstcontained java package minecraft server
worin liegt denn der prinzipielle unterschied von 4m zu container habe jetzt nur mitbekommen dass
container viele vorteile gegenüber 4m haben welche nachteile gibt es das ist grundsätzlich was
komplett unterschiedlich ist eine vm ist oder auch hypervisor je nachdem wie man das nennt ist ein
stück software der tut so als wäre ein eigener rechner mit eigener hardware drinne mit eigener
grafikkarte mit mit eigenem iow mit eigenen anschlüssen für die festplatte also ein system
was in der vm läuft hat erst mal so grob gesagt ist billig gesagt keine ahnung dass es in der
vm läuft natürlich kriegt das auch raus aber von der von der von der reinen lehrer hat ein
system in der vm erst mal keine ahnung dass es überhaupt in der vm läuft das heißt die
isolierung in der vm ist auch deutlich besser cpu mäßig macht es keinen allzu großen unterschied
das finde ich auch so ein bisschen ein misstöterium was so ein bisschen so einen so ein mythos was
manche leute aufgesetzt sind dass eine vm so wahnsinnig viel aufer hat hätte hat sie aber
eher was speicherplatz und ram belegung angeht weniger was cpu angeht also wenn man mal ein cpu
benchmark auf dem haus laufen lässt und in der vm laufen lässt da ist kaum unterschied
dazwischen weil die cpu tatsächlich so ziemlich das einzige in der vm ist die nicht komplett
nachgebaut emuliert ist sondern da wird assembler mäßig ein bisschen was umgeschrieben ich habe
keine ahnung wie es genau funktioniert muss ich ehrlich sagen aber nachdem jetzt alle modernen
cpus und chipset auch virtualisierungs hat wenn wir drauf aufgebaut haben ist das kein problem
cpu performance in der vm also du hast mehr oder weniger native cpu performance in der vm macht
eigentlich keinen großen unterschied und seitdem man jetzt auch im chipsatz und überall noch
virtualisierungsfunktion drin hatte ist auch in der vm nicht mehr so das große problem allerdings
eine vm braucht deutlich mehr speicherplatz und auch im prinzip mehr mehr ressourcen insgesamt
als ein container warum weil eine vm einfach alles bis auf die cpu und teilweise aber auf jeden
fall immer noch einen großen batzen ei auch emuliert nachbaut dementsprechend brauchen
es immer langsamer und hat braucht immer mehr ressourcen als wenn du den prozess direkt auf
dem host system startest und wenn du wenn du einen container startest ist es nichts anderes als wenn
du den prozess direkt auf dem host system startest außer dass noch ein bisschen sendbox geschichten
im kernel existieren die diesem prozess vor ein paar abstraktionsschichten vorgaukeln so der
hostname kann anders sein die netzwerk die die netzwerkgeschichte kann anders sein aber im
prinzip läuft ein container ist ein stink normaler prozess auf diesem linux host sowohl
performance mäßig als auch restriktions mäßig außen drum herum da ist kein unterschied du hast
ein paar sandbox geschichten sie groups namespaces und solche geschehen hast du drum herum um den
prozess aber es kein unterschied deswegen kannst du auch in einer vm kernel module nachladen und in
einem container nicht weil ein container läuft auf dem host betriebssystem und wenn dir ein kernel
modul fehlt was die software im container braucht dann geht es nicht es sei denn du lädst das kernel
modul im host nach und dann ist es für alle geladen in einer vm kannst du eine linux kernel
modul laden und es interessiert außer diese vm kein mensch oder keine keine andere kiste
das ist das große unterschied dazwischen kennst du dich mit mainframe ausleihen
galaga galaga fünf monate huge sub dankeschön
so ich glaube jetzt habe ich nichts mehr übersehen irgendjemand hat gefragt wie sich der azubi
angestellt hat in der ersten woche tatsächlich gar nicht so schlecht also den fritzbox test konnten
wir nicht machen weil die fritzbox gerade benutzt wurde aber da hat sich ganz gut angestellt eine
sache die mir bei azubis in letzter zeit letzten paar jahren schon aufgefallen ist ich weiß nicht
so genau wo das herkommt ehrlich gesagt dass ich die meisten nicht alle aber dass ich die meisten
unglaublich geil finden wenn sie anrücken so nach dem motto wenn du die fragst ja was hast
du schon so gemacht oder wie schätzt du dich ein in dem bereich kommt als erstes so die antwort
so nach dem orter habe schon viel gemacht sehr gut sehr gute kenntnisse diesem bereich was
eigentlich so gut wie nie stimmt ich weiß gar nicht wo diese ultra selbstüberschätzung von manchen
leuten immer herkommt das das legt sich dann relativ schnell wenn sie feststellen dass sie doch nicht so
viel ahnung haben in dem bereich aber ich weiß gar nicht wo diese wo diese extreme selbstüberschätzung
von vielen leuten herkommt exquisite knowledge aber der hat sich gut angestellt hat auch nicht
gar so übertrieben dass er sich zu geil findet auch wenn er am anfang bisschen ein bisschen viel
erzählt hat wie toll er ist und wir haben wir haben nicht so viel gemacht wir haben bisschen
geht grundlagen gemacht und er durfte er durfte ein paar linux vms installieren mit webserver
drauf und darauf eine welt weltzeit uhr webseite programmieren also sprich die muster natürlich
in git versionieren und dann auf unser auf unser reposerver pushen dass er das mal ein
bisschen geübt hat und dann hat eine webseite mit javascript die sich einmal in der sekunde
aktualisiert und die urzeit anzeigt lokal er hat es ein bisschen umständlich gemacht er hat
ein bisschen umständlich gemacht er hat beispielsweise das ganze daytime handling
hardcoded in javascript danach dem motto if minutes größer zehn dann append null und
solche dinge davor aber auf die idee musste erst mal kommen deswegen habe ich da gar nichts
zu gesagt ich habe gesagt er könnte es einfacher machen mit eingebauten funktionen die drinnen
sind aber es ist mir fast lieber wie das gemacht hat weil dann sehe ich wenigstens programmier
logik mäßig ein bisschen was kann ist der anwendungsentwickler zu binden ist eine gute
frage ich glaube nicht glaube da ist system integrations azubi aber ich habe es schon
oft gesagt dass sich die ausbildung auch von dem was man spielt dass es da nicht so wirklich
großartig unterschied mehr gibt als system integrator muss sich null programmiert kommt
drauf an wo du bist das ist genauso wie du nicht sagen kannst du musst als anwendungsentwickler
dich nie per ssh auf dem system einloggen und webserver installieren das ist halt einfach
nicht mehr so das hat 80 prozent überschneidung der bronco dann liegt das aber an dem ausbilder
beziehungsweise den betrieb das wichtigste wenn man wenn man irgendwo eine ausbildung
macht ist gar nicht mal so sehr also ok es kommt drauf an wenn man wenn man prinzipiell
vor hat und bei dem laden bleiben wollen bleiben möchte danach ja dann muss man sich natürlich
auch dementsprechend gut verkaufen also sprich dann muss manchmal auch so dass was man lernt
zurückstehen hinter dem dass man sich jetzt irgendwo gut verkaufen kann aber das beste
was man machen kann ist eigentlich wirklich so viel wie es geht in dem bereich das habe
ich schon ganz oft gesagt so viel wie es geht in dem bereich der einem spaß war erst mal
muss man rauskriegen welcher bereich einem gefällt und dann so viel wie irgendwie geht
in dem bereich der einem gefällt lernen weil umso besser man in dem bereich ist der einem
gefällt umso einfacher ist es später in dem bereich zu arbeiten der einem gefällt und
wenn man in dem bereich arbeiten kann der einem gefällt wird man auch noch besser in dem
bereich natürlich kann man das dann alles noch ein bisschen erweitern und andere richtungen
gehen und kann dann quasi in dem bereich arbeiten sich später mehr oder weniger sogar ganz
gut die jobs aussuchen in dem bereich der einem gefällt und sogar noch ordentlich geld
verdienen als wenn man keinen plan hat oder was macht wo man keinen bock drauf hat weil
wirklich gut werden das versuche ich auch unseren azubis manchmal ein bisschen zu erzählen
aber es ist schwierig zu zu vermitteln und es ist ja auch nur meine ansicht dass man wirklich
gut nur in einem bereich wird für den man sich interessiert das ist egal ob das jetzt
irgendein technischer bereich ist oder ob jetzt einer gerne muster strickt oder oder
fische fängt oder sonst was also sprich jeder hat irgendwas was er gerne macht irgendwas
was ihn wahnsinnig interessiert das ist egal das kann auch können auch was weiß ich es
kann alles sein ja aber nur wenn du in diesem bereich was machst wirst du richtig gut werden
es gibt genug genau genau also vor allem das ist halt auch was wo man sich in der regel
privat für interessiert es gibt genug leute die müssen irgendeinen scheiß auf der arbeit
machen indem sie nicht gut sind auf den sie keinen bock haben den sie halt machen muss
um geld zu verdienen das heißt es ist ein richtiger also es ist ein unglaublicher vorteil
wenn man die möglichkeit hat in einem bereich zu arbeiten den man gerne macht und für den
man sich interessiert und das kann man halt auch nur wenn man sich gut auskennt und und
das geht da wie ist ja das geht halt so hand in hand wenn man sich auskennt wird man logischerweise
auch besser in dem bereich weil es eben einen interessiert wenn man sich permanent für irgendwas
quälen muss dann nicht zum beispiel wo ich mich immer dazu quälen muss ist microsoft office zu
verwenden ich krieg anfälle wenn ich wenn ich office verwenden muss so und letztens kam mein
mein chef zu mir machen das video machen wir können es mal gucken ob das wirklich was taugt
klein letztens kam ein chef zu mir hat gemeint hier guck mal ich habe davon in einem projekt so
eine komische so eine komische serverliste gekriegt da stehen einfach nur namen von
servan drinne und ich weiß nicht was das ist ob ich ob ich das kenne an die tech hier haut
hier die points raus big brain ob ich die server kennen habe ich okay rucke ich mir an das war
eine riesenlange liste und natürlich in excel was sonst ja also da gibt es auch dieses dieses
minibild it hieß er hieß er nicht atlas der typ bei den griechen der der das gebirge auf dem auf
dem rücken getragen der die welt auf dem rücken getragen hat da gibt es da gibt es dieses minibild
wo irgendwie der typ steht mit mit der welt auf dem rücken und auf auf dem rücken steht halt it
und unten drunter steht halt ne susifus war der das der den berg hoch gerollt hat und unten
drunter steht dann halt oben drüber ist halt it und unten drunter steht halt excel so nach dem
motto excel trägt alles so und so wie das halt ist war das natürlich eine excel liste die ich
da ausfüllen sollte und da war ich natürlich nicht sonderlich scharf drauf aber ich mein
letztendlich ist auch doof wenn ich da beim chef sagen würde sucht ihr für excel jemand
anderes ja außerdem ich weil ich kenne die kisten ja das wäre für alle beteiligten blöd
gewesen wenn ich wenn ich das nicht gemacht hätte und da habe ich mich hingesetzt freitags
und habe den kram ausgefüllt so und noch nicht noch nicht genug der dinger es war nicht nur excel
es war excel in confluence vielleicht kennen das die alle anderen das ist von atlas den wiki
ist das und das ist ganz abartig diese kombination leute ist das ist das ist wirklich der teufel in
personen 3 hat das ist wirklich der teufel in personen und das funktioniert folgendermaßen
es gibt es gibt eine confluence kompanion app das sieht dann so aus genauso genauso also man
hat in diesem wiki man hat in diesem wiki ein angehängtes excel das ist quasi der größte
schitt aus beiden welten das ist der größte schitt aus excel aus excel auf windows share
liegen und aus komischen wiki also die haben ein excel dokument haben die angehängt an die
seite im confluence und dieses excel dokument kannst du nur über confluence öffnen und dann
aber auch nur wenn die kompanion app installiert ist und die kompanion app download das als
attachment öffnet es im excel und wenn du es im excel speicherst kannst du upload drücken und
es lädt es wieder in confluence hoch was ein bullshit alter wer sich das ausgedacht hat den
gehört der hat geschlagen das ist komplett komplett wir komplett wir zumindest aber gut was sollste
machen muss den kram editieren oder habe ich es editiert und das ist jeden zweiten upload
abgebrochen ich habe absolute anfälle gekriegt das hat einfach nicht funktioniert mit dem upload
so irgendwann habe ich dann gesagt ok was was ich habe ein bisschen geflammt in dem in dem in dem
in dem kommentarbereich habe ich jetzt absolute zumutung mit mit excel den kram bearbeiten zu
müssen ich lade mir das jetzt runter und lade es danach wieder hoch habe ich gemacht und am
anderen am anderen tag wo ich dann wo ich dann wieder auf der arbeit war so irgendwie dienstag
war das glaube ich auf der arbeit war hat diejenige die diesen auftrag ursprünglich mal meinen chef
gegeben hat mit dieser komischen excel excel liste da hat er das ticket reingeschrieben also
ich habe mit dem excel upload überhaupt keine probleme wie passt es dir denn am 28.1 ob ich
noch eine excel schulung eine eine confluence excel schulung haben will haben möchte da war
ich mir jetzt nicht so sicher ob die mich ärgern will weil ich irgendwie das heilige confluence
geflammt habe oder ob die das ernst meint ich bin mir nicht so ganz sicher ob die das ernst meint
wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich meint ihr das ernst wahrscheinlich meint ihr das wirklich
wahrscheinlich meint ihr das wirklich hilfreich so und ich habe ihr dann sogar ich habe ich
habe dann zurückgeschrieben noch das ist ein bekannter fehler ich bin extra in den
bug tracker gegangen von atlasien und habe ein ticket rausgesucht was genau diesen upload
fehler beschreibt das ist nämlich so wenn die session timeout im hintergrund und die
standard session timeout nach 60 minuten dann bricht der upload über diese companion app
ab ohne fehlermeldung das ist ein bekannter fehler bei atlasien gibt sogar tickets bei denen gibt
sogar tickets das ticket habe ich dann auch reingepostet das ist ein bekannter fehler der
tritt tritt hat nun mal auf oder hat sie wieder geschrieben so nach dem motto ja also bei ihr
tritt das nicht auf und ich soll noch vorbeikommen wenn ich die excel schulung haben will was
schreibt was schreibe ich da jetzt drauf wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich schreibe ich
ganz wahrscheinlich schreibe ich ganz sachlich so nach dem motto danke für das angebot aber
eine excel schulung muss nicht sein wie sowas also ich mein bauch bauchmäßig würde ich da
drauf antworten gehen wir weg mit dem scheiß tool aber das will ich nicht will ich nicht ins ticket
schreiben das müsste ich schreibe ich überlege mir gerade ich überlege mir mal ich bin einfach
als kommentar ins ticket post drunter das müsste ich machen einfach nur excel schulung ich muss
da nicht hin ich muss mir nur noch eine ausrede ausdenken genau gut jetzt habe ich
lange rum geschwänzt heute
wir gucken wir uns mal den 1000 euro gaming pc an was ist eine gute alternative zu
confluence fragt der alex 25 ganz ehrlich meiner meinung nach die beste alternative
zu confluence ist ein klassisches doku wiki das ist old school ja gebe ich zu aber doku wiki
hat einen riesen vorteil der finde ich ziemlich unterschätzt wird doku wiki braucht keine
datenbank doku wiki ist rein plaintext also sprich du hast die ganzen sachen im textformat
auf der platte liegen was auch ganz okay ist ist bookstack allerdings also kostenlos also
an kostenlosen wir reden jetzt auch für kostenlosen alternativen bookstack ist auch
ganz okay kommt confluence eigentlich am nächsten von allen kostenlosen geschichten
allerdings hat bookstack keine möglichkeit sachen automatisch zu updaten also sprich
wenn man beispielsweise eine liste erstellen möchte möchte von oder mal angenommen man
hat eine liste von allen seinen servan im heimnetzwerk oder von allen von allen rechnern
im heimnetzwerk mit einer kleinen beschreibung dazu sowas hatten wir ganz gerne mal im doku
wiki könnte man zum beispiel im doku wiki total einfach mit 23 zeilen shell script könnte
man quasi jeden server pingen lassen und das und das ergebnis in eine tabelle schreiben
oder den server durchstreichen lassen der nicht erreichbar war für eine gewisse ist
ist relativ einfach man gibt auch andere möglichkeiten sowas machst du eigentlich mit monitoring
system aber nur mal so jetzt als beispiel was man halt schönes damit machen kann dass
doku wiki seiten einfach plaintext sind sowas geht halt in in bookstack nicht für mich
eines der größten probleme an bookstack dass die eben keine ordentliche api haben oder
haben sie mittlerweile eine api feedback aha die haben mittlerweile eine guck mal seit
sieben tagen haben sie eine api wie auch immer wie auch immer die funktioniert muss müsste
man müsste man sich mal anschauen aber doku wiki ist für mich immer noch die beste variante
einfach als total light white total simpel und einfach alles plaintext ist und es gibt
ein paar ganz gute diems dass es nicht so old school aussieht ich finde doku wiki ist
toll gibt auch ein halbwegs brauchbares markdown plugin doku wiki ist für einfache sachen
und auch für teams finde ich immer noch die beste variante was ist mit media wiki finde
ich komplizierter als doku wiki dabei genauso
hast du mitbekommen dass das neue office update bei allen browsers bing als standard suchmaschine
forciert nein habe ich nicht habe ich nicht mitgekriegt
wundert mich auch nicht das ist microsoft taktik
boomer excel ok dann gucken wir uns das ganze mal an was was sagt er findet ihr nicht auch
dass hardware rad und hardware deals total ähnliche begrüßung haben die sagen die
auch schon das sagen die auch schon so so gleich haben die was mit hallo hallo und willkommen
bei hartz verrat das hört sich voll gleich an hey leute und herzlich willkommen bei hardware
deals heute gehts weiter mit dem 10.000 euro pc und damit dem core 1000d projekt wir haben
den pc jetzt endlich fertig gebaut und ich finde das ergebnis kann sich auch wirklich
sehen lassen um kostet er bitteschön 10.000 euro was hat er da eingebaut gibt es da irgendwie
eine komponentenliste oder so die nicht recht links sind
etwas was nicht recht links ist ja anscheinend nicht na gut man muss ja sehen wo man bleibt
denn dafür dass es wirklich meine allererste custom wasserkühlung natürlich abgesehen
vom legendären bierkühlung ok bin ich optisch wirklich sehr zufrieden mit dem teil und auch
der time lapse der wirklich super viel arbeit war ist richtig richtig gut bei euch angekommen
und hat inzwischen schon über 250.000 aber 10.000 euro was mussten da alles rein machen
für die vergoldete pipes oder ihr das video noch nicht gesehen habt dann kann ich euch
nur empfehlen das nachzuholen denn wir haben da wirklich einen hardware porn vom aller
feinsten gedreht heute geht sie in das finale video zu dem pc wir werden das teil ausführlich
testen also durch die üblichen benchmarks und spieletest jagen über die übertaktung
und temperaturen sprechen und ob da drauf auf exe ob der excel drauf läuft excel 365
ob es das kann andere kritische wort verlieren und meint ihr meint ihr das excel raytracing
plugin funktioniert wusste dir das excel excel in den rtx on raytracing das excel
in raytracing renderer hat hier passbar auf hier raytracing in excel excellent excellent
leute ich meine allein schon so was funktioniert wtf wofür weil es funktioniert
so und wenn wir uns jetzt mal das ist das ist das sourcecode dazu das schlimme ist nein
gehe weg ich will mir das angucken ich will es nicht öffnen ich will mir den inhalt
angucken es scheint ganz schön viel makro geschichten zu sein das ist binary xlsb btf
binary excel file was es nicht alles gibt gut gucken wir weiter so viel kann ich schon
mal vorweg nehmen es funktioniert leider nicht alles so reibungslos wie man denken könnte
und gerade sli beziehungsweise nv link haben in der praxis einige probleme gemacht diese
leise dieses video wurde freundlicherweise gesponsert von wobei geht ein bisschen lauter
Leute ein bisschen lauter oder ein shop für neue und originale produktschlüssel wewindows
10 offers virenschutz und sogar serverprodukte verkauft werden hier ausschließlich neue
und legale lizenzen die auch garantiert dauerhaft gültig sind viele andere besonders günstige
shops verkaufen oftmals schon gebrauchte keys einfach weiter hier kann es sein dass
diese irgendwann nicht mehr funktionieren oder sogar gesperrt werden bei lizenz ja ja
was das ist absolut keine sorge die konfiguration des pc sollte inzwischen in den meisten von
euch bekannt sein aber falls ihr noch kein video zu dem pc gesehen habt verbaut ist ein
intel core i9 ihr könnt auch alternativ bei mir einfach am twitch prime sub dalassen aus
900 x 10 kernprozessor mit 20 freizeit bis zu 4,3 gigahertz turbotakt natürlich habe
ich die cpu geköpft und mit flüssigmetall ausgestattet natürlich was sonst was hat
er für eine cpu drin i9 warum denn ihn warum kein i10 heißt nicht wie heißen die neun
jetzt i10 i10 9000 irgendwas oder gibt's warum warum denn so ein ach i9 9000 ja ja ja
10.000 genau i9 10.000 irgendwas warum warum warum den warum den und kein kein ich hab
sagt ich kenne mich dabei inter aktuell grad nicht so zwischen den unterschieden aus ich
weiß nur dass die unterschiedlich also groß sind so bis zu 4,3 gigahertz turbotakt wie viel
im pc gesehen haben ist ein intel core i9 7900 x 10 kernprozessor mit 20 freizeit bis zu 4,3
gigahertz turbotakt natürlich habe ich die cpu geköpft und mit flüssigmetall natürlich weil
die x 299 habe ich geschwitzt ich habe so krass geschwitzt dass ich erzähle es jedes mal wenn
ich ein seine cpu köpfen sehe ich habe so krass geschwitzt als den 8700 k geköpft habe und
flüssigmetall drauf gemacht hat vor allem weil zu dem damaligen zeitpunkt die dinger nicht
lieferbar waren hätte ich das ding geschrottert hätte ich ein halbes jahr später aus dem pc
bauen können und wer sich die frage stellt warum ich hier auf so eine in anführungszeichen alte
cpu gesetzt habe das projekt ist schon seit über einem jahr in arbeit und damals gab es
noch keine guten alternativen wie zum beispiel in 3900 oder 3950 scheint sehr komplex zu sein
den kram auszutauschen und ja darum natürlich auch die anzahl der pci express lanes war zu
dem zeitpunkt der 7900 x hat er voll gelohnt mit 10.000 euro rechner zu bauen mit veralterter
technik die beste wahl auch wenn ich jetzt wahrscheinlich eher zu was anderen greifen würde
excellent haben wir die cpu natürlich übertaktet und zwar auf 4,7 gigahertz auf allen kernen und
das bei 1,26 volt einfach weil das bei unserem modell der sweet spot war was stromverbrauch
temperaturen und natürlich die leistung angeht der cpu stehen insgesamt 64 gigabyte korser
dominator platinum ddr 4 hoffentlich mit rgb 1600 megahertz zur seite und bei den grafikkarten
kommen zwei nvidia rtx 2080 tis zum einsatz die mit jetzt weiß ich auch warum das ding 10.000
euro kostet so eine grafikkarte kostet ja schon wie viel kostet 1.400 oder so
ja 1200
verbunden sind außerdem wurden die kühler von der founders edition mit hydro x wasserblöcken
von korser ausgetauscht und vor allem bessere übertaktungsergebnisse aber es ist immer noch
ist immer noch viel raum zu 10.000 euro bei dem punkt bin ich auch wirklich begeistert von den
karten denn wir haben es bei beiden karten geschafft den speicher um 1100 megahertz zu
übertakten der speichertakt beträgt jetzt also 16.200 megahertz und auch bei den chips hatten wir
glück da war nämlich immerhin 100 speichertakt bringt nicht viel spiel und benchmark zu einem
effektiven takt von knapp 2100 also speichern also ganz ehrlich leute ram übertakten sowohl
gpu als auch system ram übertakten ist eigentlich das von allen übertaktungsvarianten das das
sinnloseste megahertz und gerade bei ram übertakten handelt fängt man sich gerne nervige fehler ein
also cpu übertakten bin ich immer dabei grafikkarte übertakten bin ich auch immer dabei aber
ram übertakten bei amd ist was anderes ja das da hast du recht bei amd ist ein bisschen was
anderes aber ram übertakten ist also generell das macht keinen so großen unterschied außer
dass man ekliche fehler kriegt und das ganze eben mal zwei leistungsmäßig also aber auch
bei der gpu bringt ram übertakten nicht wahnsinnig viel grafikkarten angeht das stärkste was ich
jemals hier auf dem channel für euch bauen und natürlich testen durfte und bevor wir jetzt
gleich direkt zu den benchmarks und spieletests kommen will ich vorher noch das thema temperaturen
ansprechen denn auch die können sich wirklich sehen lassen wir haben ja insgesamt drei
radiatoren verbaut zwei 480 millimeter modelle für den grafikkarten kreislauf und 360 millimeter
radiator hat er auch seine ssd übertaktet für die cpu und das merkt man auch gerade bei den
grafikkarten konnte ich wirklich kaum meinen augen trauen egal wie lange man zockt und welches
bode heinhard ist da ich hoffe nicht dass du mein azubi bist weil er heißt auch heinrich
benchmark man laufen lässt selbst bei 100 prozent auslastung von beiden karten gleichzeitig haben
sich die temperaturen immer um die 40 grad bewegt also ein wert den die meisten luftgekühlten
grafikkarten im windows betrieb erreichen und das ganze dann auch noch nahezu laut los weil
sich die lüfte auf den radiatoren mit nicht mal 800 umdrehungen pro minute drehen wirklich
beeindruckend ist bei der cpu natürlich nicht ganz so gut aus obwohl sie geköpft ist und trotz
wasserkühlung erreichen wir hier in cinebench von um die 70 grad und auch wenn das nicht wirklich
bedenklich ist oder so in der cpu wäre wahrscheinlich 20 grad kühler geblieben trotzdem natürlich
kein vergleich zu einer luftkühlung von so einem system und damit kommen wir jetzt auch schon direkt
zu dem benchmark so ein spieletest ich habe mich aufgepasst wie viel ram hat er wie viel ram hatte
er und ihr habt ihr habt mehr aufgepasst als ich wie viel ram ist drinne 234 64 64 ok
erreichen wir im cinebench r15 ich meine ich hatte mir auch den rechner zusammengestellt mit
8000 3950 x 64 g und und sonst was und wir haben glaube 3500 euro oder so ausgegeben
von 2603 punkten im multicore und 206 punkten im singel core was wirklich ein gutes ergebnis
ist in 9900 900k reichen nur knapp 2000 kann man die 64 überhaupt auslassen ja kann man ein ding
vor allem wenn du paar vms an hast so rein mit mit windows dinge starten ist relativ wenig aber
wenn du wenn du vms an hast ja über 20 prozent schlechter außerdem brauchen browser heutzutage
unglaublich viel ram trotzdem und das habe ich ja schon vorher gesagt 3900 x von amd wäre in
zwischen einfach die sinnvollere weil denn für weniger geld erreicht der mit 3175 und 209 punkten
in beiden disziplinen besseres ergebnis und für die dies interessiert im neueren cinebench r20
erreicht das system 482 punkte im singel core und 6172 punkte im multicore so viel jedenfalls
schon mal zur cpu viel interessanter finde ich dann aber die synthetischen benchmarks und da
macht den anfang natürlich mal wieder 3d mark times bei je mehr ram du hast desto mehr reservieren
die programme warum programm reserviert speicher und es ist unabhängig davon wie viel speicher man
hat wenn ich sage betriebssystem gibt mir 5 mb dann sind das 5 mb egal ob ich 64 oder 32 g
ramm haben am punktzahl von 20.172 punkten davon 23.824 grafikpunkte beziehungsweise 154 und 137
fps in den beiden grafiktests und physikscore von 10.796 punkten das ist der höchste wert den
ich je in dem benchmark erreicht habe und im vergleich zu meinem schnellsten system was ich
davor zusammen bei einem 10.000 euro rechner würde ich auch erwarten dass das höchste wert ist
der jemals erreicht hat zumal es leider leider muss man sagen schon outdated technik ist er hat
was sieht ganz cool aus ein pc mit 9900 k und eine rtx 20 das ist das ist gar nicht sein rechner das
ist doch ein anderer der 92 und 84 fps erreicht hat es ist ein 60 bis 70 prozent besserer wert die
zweite grafikkarte macht sich also wirklich bemerkbar und natürlich ist der pizdei als
schulfach so richtig an der schule oder in der berufsschule jemals und weltweit getestete
systeme die 3d mark benchmark könnte ich übrigens alle selbst kostenlos runterladen falls ihr lust
habt eure systeme mal mit dem pc zu vergleichen den link übrigens das ist überhaupt keine kunst
überhaupt sein es ist keine kunst ich glaube sogar mein rechner gehört noch zu den besten
bestensystemen dann bei bei 3d mark da ist halt so viel on board crap der da getestet wird und
sowas und mein rechner ist eine ganze ecke langsamer als dieses ding ich meine ich habe
8.700 k und eine 1080 di drinnen das ist definitiv langsamer als das was er hat und jetzt gehen wir
einfach noch mal kurz die werte aus den anderen benchmarks durch im times by extreme haben wir die
gesamtpunktzahl von 12.219 punkten fehler das ist nicht daran dass wenn aus ganz gerne sachen
preloaded 20.214 punkte im firestrike ultra 15.169 gesamtpunkte davon 16.724 grafik und 22.352
für die benchmarks jucken mich jetzt nicht so hat er vielleicht ein bisschen erklärung was da genau
alles drin ist die gpu angeht ziemlich schnell wieder und 50 und durchschnittlich 110 fps zwar
ein wirklich gutes ergebnis erreicht auf lösung hochgestellt was auch tatsächlich den gewünschten
effekt hatte das cpu bottleneck ist so nicht mehr vorhanden was ist das für ein spiel das
fackrei was ist für ein game leute aber wie man sehen kann werden die beiden grafikkarten trotzdem
nicht zu 100 was ganz einfach an der schlechten programmierung des spiels liegt wir erreichen so
durchschnittlich immerhin 81 fps was in unserem fall gegenüber einer einzelnen karte aber gerade
meine steigerung von 40 prozent ist als nächstes war dann shadow of the tomb raider dran und was
soll ich sagen das spiel ist wirklich beschissen optimiert wenn es darum geht mehrere grafikkarten
zu nutzen wir erreichen den benchmark zwar weit über 100 fps auf höchsten einstellungen und in
4k auf lösungen haben gegenüber einer einzelnen karte also knapp 70 prozent mehrleistung dafür
stürzt das spiel aber die ganze zeit ab und ich bin da deswegen heute das ist der grund warum ich
auf die frage ob sli oder nicht sli immer sage eine fettere grafikkarte ist besser als eine kleinere
grafikkarte mit sli der einzige die einzige kombination wo es sinn macht mit sli ist das
wie er das hat die high end grafikkarte zu nehmen und zwei stück davon reinzubauen und selbst da
ist wie man hier sieht fängt man sich probleme mit ein
welche gpu und cpu würdest du aktuell empfehlen kommt da jeweils quartal 2 neues von nvidia und
da bin ich der falsche für ich kenne mich damit immer genauso zu diesem zeitpunkt aus wenn ich
mir rechner kaufen würde also aktuell würde ich mir 3950 x kaufen als cpu 16 kehren wenn ich mir
jetzt was kaufen würde und als grafikkarte kommt man an den 2080 ti kaum vorbei wenn man high end
will dreis leistungsmäßig ist natürlich ganz was anderes angesagt aber keine ahnung da bin ich
der falsche für das großartige kaufberatung da kann ich mich zu schlecht aus auf eine gamers nexus
haben auch mal einen test mit zwei 2080 tis gemacht und auch die haben an der stelle die
gleiche erfahrung machen müssen zum glück sind nicht alle spiele so schlecht optimiert und es gibt
wirklich titel in denen sli beziehungsweise in wie link sehr gut funktioniert dazu gehören vor
allem ältere titel die noch auf direkt 11 basieren wie zum beispiel gta 5 das läuft auf
höchsten einstellungen und in 4k auflösung einfach mal mit weit über 100 fps und wie man
sehen kann werden auch wirklich beide grafikkarten schön ausgelastet obwohl wir gta typisch leicht
im cbu limit sind erreicht man in etwa 70 prozent besseren wert als mit einer einzelnen grafikkarte
was ich wirklich sehen lassen kann es ist tatsächlich ziemlich gut auf der 3 aus auch
das spiel der switcher mit mehreren grafikkarten skalieren das sieht man allerdings in ordentlicher
qualität der beiden karten das spiel läuft in weku hd auf höchsten einstellungen mit
durchschnittlich über 160 fps auch das kann sich wirklich sehen lassen und angesichts der
leistungen ist anscheinend auch plötzlich als nächstes werden eigentlich bettel viel fünf
an der reihe leider leider diesen realismus in der witz in der witzser serie nicht einfangen
im direkt x12 modus gar nicht mit mehreren grafikkarten arbeiten kann zwar unterstützt
der direkt x11 modus sli aber jeder der schon mal battlefield 5 gespielt hat der weiß wie
schlecht das spiel unter direkt x11 läuft und in unserem test haben wir mit einer einzelnen
karte in direkt x12 bessere ergebnisse als mit zwei karten unter direkt x11 erreicht so
dass auch das eigentlich gar keinen sinn macht ihr seht also das ganze ist ein zweischneidiges
schwert es gibt anwendungsfälle und das haben vor allem die benchmarks gezeigt in denen
nv link wirklich sehr gut funktioniert und wir quasi die gamingleistung unseres systems
verdoppeln können aber in vielen fällen ist es halt so dass neue spiele entweder gar
keinen support für mehrere grafikkarten haben oder das ganze so schlecht implementiert ist
dass man lieber auf einer einzelnen karte spielt und ich denke das liegt daran dass
multi gpu systeme immer weniger relevant werden man könnte fast sagen auch immer auch für
entwickler zumindest im gaming sektor in meinen augen macht so eine sli beziehungsweise nv link
konfiguration aktuell nur sind wenn man schon vorher genau weiß was man damit vorhat also
welche spiele man spielen möchte auf welchen einstellungen warum ist der rechner denn so
teuer lösungen weil gerade bei 4k gaming kommt man oftmals am cpu bottleneck und keine
mehrleistung dann auch wirklich ich meine sagen wir mal 2500 euro grafikkarte 800 euro cpu
die kommt er auf 10.000 euro ich will die ref links jetzt nicht anklicken gleich die wasserkühlung
vielleicht vielleicht
was findest du zukunftsaugliche hdmi oder displayport beides beides hdmi ist eher so
im entertainment fernsehbereich und displayport halt eher am desktop beides mit beides am start
bleiben auch ok der track stream hat er noch gesagt er macht abby am bk was denn bk berufskolleg
oder was bei was bk und wir haben technische informatik als leistungsgröße das wird aufgesplittet
auf je einen kurs datenbanken netzwerk technische microcontroller technik um triebsystem ist
alles wichtig microcontroller ist so eine sache wo ich sagen würde das braucht man
am wenigsten wenn man nicht gerade in diesem bereich ist ja aber microcontroller an sich
ist ein sehr interessantes thema weil man da lernt ordentlich zu programmieren weil
die dinger halt ressourcentechnisch ein bisschen bisschen beschränkt sind übrigens mein dotnet
mein dotnet microcontroller ist am freitag angekommen hier das ding hat ja ich hatte
hier gebacked und der erste microcontroller dem man mit c sharp und dotnet programmieren
kann ja das ding ich bin mal gespannt wie gut das funktioniert weil das steht und fällt
natürlich auch mit libraries die du hast für sensoren und sowas das heißt rein mit
dotnet und c sharp gewinnt man da noch kein blumentopf es braucht halt passen libraries
ja du brauchst libraries für displays für 1000 verschiedene sensoren hat sie scharpe
nicht so viel so viel aufwarten für so wenig ressourcen das ding hat das ding ist gar nicht
so so schlecht was da drauf ist das kommt auf die dotnet implementierung an diese haben
ich mein guck mal die haben da ein dual core oder ein single core 216 megahertz cpu drauf
16 mb ram das ist krass viel das ist das ist mega viel 16 mb ram für solche dinger 16
mb ram ist übertrieben viel und 32 mb flash ist auch übertrieben viel das ist fast schon
mini computer also also 16 nur mal so als beispiel ein esp 866 hat 40 kilobyte ram den
man verwenden kann und ein mb maximal firmware größe und mit dem 23 mit dem esp 82 26 kann
man auch so ziemlich alles machen was man machen will schon ein taschenrechner hat
ein mb also wie gesagt in esp 2866 das sind ja so mit aktuell die mit mit dem esp 32 zusammen
so die beliebtesten microcontroller der hat 40 kilobyte ram den man verwenden kann und
40 kilobyte ist auch schon ganz schön viel im vergleich zu anderen also ja ich finde
das alles alles wichtig track stream und netzwerk technik ist saumäßig wichtig übrigens habe
subs übersehen burpel twitch prime vier monate dankeschön huge subs habe ich noch
was übersehen ich gucke gerade mal ne sieht nicht so aus falls ich was übersehen habt
flame mich mal
was guckst du gleich noch das sushi burger video kann man machen sushi burger ich kann
mir nicht vorstellen dass es gut schmeckt kannst du für einen anfänger irgendwelche
projekte mit dem raspberry pi empfehlen die im heimbereich nutzen haben das ist sehr individuell
also was du machen kannst was was bringt ist sowas hier aber das ist einfach installiert
und gut ist es bringt auch mittlerweile leider nicht mehr so viel wie noch von vor eineinhalb
jahren oder zwei jahren es könnte es ist echt sehr sehr individuell was du da machen willst
der richtung heim automatisierung richtig in was auch immer kann ich so pauschal so pauschal
nicht sagen und was hast du damit vor ausprobieren nichts spezielles hast du eine sprache am liebsten
programmierst ja es ist so so 50 50 c-sharp oder ruby allerdings ist ist ruby überhaupt
nicht mal angesagt sie haben es mit rails auch ein bisschen verkackt ok sushi chef moment
es ist es ist gar kein sushi burger es ist gebated der sushi typ hat den burger erfunden
dazu kann ich bloß sagen das ist für so eine sendung wo sie nachdem nachdem der gekocht
hat alle dargestellt ist das gut exquisite exquisite geschmack jetzt so ist das so wie
ein koch sendung im fernsehen wo sie sich auch immer danach gegenseitig feiern wie geil
das essen schmeckt der burger michaela muss die recht geben so geil sah der burger gar
nicht aus gone ramsey koenig der weiß nicht nicht meins ok was haben wir ich habe so viele
videos offen lieber die wir uns angucken können ja autosecure your network da bin ich mal
gespannt ich mein ich gucke so videos normalerweise nicht aber das hat gute bewertung das heißt
das ist schon mal sinnvoll was der erzählt und da bin ich mal gespannt was ich dafür
mein senf dazu geben kann was haben wir sonst noch so mehr war du das in linux linux will
es die coolen leute immer sagen linux das wollen wir uns jetzt nicht angucken so dann
haben wir noch das warum habe ich denn das auf das beste raspberry pie case jetzt tatsächlich
interessant weil ich brauche auch eins was ist das kairo meco es na das ist das glaube
ich zu harte koste aber das wollen sie mal nach angucken drei neue doom level haben wir
am start reactos das ist zu lang das gucken wir uns auch irgendwann mal vielleicht an
aber nicht hier moin der patrick ist auch am start dann haben wir noch ambylite selbst
bauen why i why i stop playing battlefield 5 in das wird mich mal interessieren weil
das ist ja so der fernbauer schlechthin ja react gibt es noch also reactos gibt es noch
aber das ist immer noch kacke top 10 new open world games of 2020 das gucken wir uns jetzt
mal an weil ich ziemlich sicher bin dass ich keines der games spielen werde
ihr wisst dass ich kein großer open world fan bin ein sicher open world oder einzigen
zwei open world games die mir gefallen haben ist breath of the wild und der switcher drei
doch cyberpunk spiele ich vielleicht
final fantasy 7 das wird so abkacken leute ich sage es euch das wird so abscheißen
das kommt auch 20 20 daraus was ist das ist das ein
ja ja game
Das ist ein... ein Weeps-out-Game.
Ja, Sleeping Crystal, ähnlich.
Und weiter zu Nummer 9 ist Dying Light 2, welches eigentlich eine sehr große Menge von Ideen zu einem schon ziemlich guten Spiel, Dying Light 1.
Natürlich werden wir die Parkour-Skills des originalen Spiels sehen.
Sie verbreiten die Zahl der Parkour-Movie.
Aber der große Entwicklung ist die Emphasis auf die Narrative.
Sie versuchen, etwas verrücktes, enttäuschendes zu machen.
Ich weiß, dass Dying Light 1 ziemlich gut gewesen sein soll. Also es kann durchaus sein, dass es auch was taugt.
Aber Zombie-Games sind bei mir... out.
Was wurde auf undurchgratte Zeit verschoben, okay?
Das... das finde ich gut. Das finde ich gut. Ich finde es auch bei Cyberpunk gut.
Wenn die sagen, das ist noch nicht so weit, dann soll das verschieben.
Früher... jetzt muss da... jetzt kommt wieder hier... Wub-Old.
Früher war das ganz normal, dass Spiele verschoben werden.
Das war fast schon Standard, dass Spiele verschoben wurden.
Aber heute ist das halt nicht mehr so.
Heute wird das Zeug lieber rausgekloppt.
Was?
Tatsächlich. Ja, tatsächlich.
Es hat tatsächlich ein bisschen was von...
Das ist so ein typisches Spiel, wo man sagen kann, das ist...
Also der hat ja gerade gesagt, it's very pretty, nur wenn man den Grafikstil mag.
Ansonsten ist das eher nicht so was.
Ich meine, schön gemacht ist es hier, aber wenn man den Grafikstil nicht mag, ist es nicht pretty, dann sieht das...
Halt so aus, als gefällt es an mich.
Moment.
Das ist jetzt ein anderes Game als das davor.
Das sieht genauso aus.
Das sah genauso aus.
Okay, juckt mich, juckt mich nicht.
Also wenn es Ubisoft ist, wissen wir jetzt schon, dass du auf jeden Fall auf Türme klettern wirst.
Und Aussichtspunkte und Camps einnehmen.
Es gibt ein paar Sachen, die müssen alle Ubisoft-Games haben.
Kommt da, da kann man dann Hochklettern und Aussichtspunkt synchronisieren.
Und es wird an jeder Ecke irgendeine unsinnige Kiste mit unsinniger Ingame-Währung sein.
Weil man kriegt es ja nicht hin, bei Ubisoft, mittlerweile zumindest, die Welt von sich aus interessant zu gestalten,
man macht einfach eine große Welt und stellt an jeder Ecke irgendwie eine Schatzkiste oder sowas hin mit unsinnigem Inhalt.
Die Hand ist ein Aussichtspunkt 100%
Ich würde gerade sagen, ist das immer noch nicht raus?
Das sieht doch ganz okay aus.
Zumindest wisst ihr, was ich in Mittelalter-Games immer sehr positiv finde, wenn die Leute nicht dreckig aussehen.
Weil in allen Filmen, oder guckt euch, eines der krassesten Beispiele war die Witcher-Serie.
Es waren alle Leute permanent dreckig im Mittelalter, wenn man nach Fernsehsendungen geht.
Immer! Die stehen auf dem Marktplatz und sind dreckig. Die sind, keine Ahnung, die fahren auf dem Wagen oder so rum, sind dreckig.
Die Leute im Mittelalter waren nicht dreckig, die konnten sich durchaus auch mal wäschen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie die da auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen sind, dass die im Mittelalter alle dreckig waren.
Witcher ist viel zu sauber. Die Gesichter haben sich immer schön vollgeschmiert der Leute mit Dreck.
Der Rest ja. Aber über die Witcher-Serie könnte ich mich eh noch lange auslassen.
Ich habe jetzt ja fertig geguckt. Ich muss sagen, das muss jetzt mal kurz los werden, nachdem ich die Witcher-Serie fertig geguckt habe.
An sich muss ich sagen, es ist eine ganz gute Serie geworden. Nachdem ich die erste Folge geguckt habe, wusste ich gar nicht, ob ich weitergucken soll.
Ich fand auch, die erste Folge ist mit die schlechteste, wobei die letzten zwei auch nicht sonderlich gut gemacht sind.
Es gab zwischendurch mal gute Sachen. Auch das Treffen zwischen Geralt und Ciri fand ich ganz gut.
Die Serie war okay, aber die hätte tatsächlich richtig gut sein können.
Ein großer Kritikpunkt, den die Witcher-Serie bei mir hat, und ich habe es ja schon mal gesagt, dass ich da recht pingelig bin,
aber das macht für mich einfach auch die Atmosphäre und die Glaubwürdigkeit kaputt.
Ich spoiler nicht. Ich versuche das unmöglich spoilerfrei zu machen jetzt.
Ich sage nicht, wer, wie, was. Zum Beispiel wird Geralt gefangen genommen in einer Sendung.
Ja, der Drache sah auch schlecht aus. Zum Beispiel wurde Geralt gefangen genommen in einer Sendung, bricht dann aus
und passenderweise ist direkt vor der Gefängnistür sein Equipment.
Warum um alles in der Welt soll ich die komplette Witcher-Rüstung, Schwerter und alles direkt in die Ecke neben der Gefängnistelle legen,
dass Geralt quasi ausbrechen kann und direkt wieder equipped ist. Solche Dinge.
Das wirkt einfach sehr gezwungen, weil so nach dem Motto, es ergibt jetzt eigentlich keinen Sinn, aber es muss so sein, dass die Story jetzt weiter funktioniert.
Nee, PK habe ich ja nicht geguckt. Und was zum Teufel ist mit den Nilfgaarder Rüstungen los?
Die sehen aus, als hätten sie zu wenig Antifaltencreme aufgetragen, aber nicht, als würden sie funktionieren.
Dann gibt es ganz, ganz viele fragwürdige Taktiken, die niemals jemand in einer Schlacht so nach dem Motto so durchführen würde.
Zum Beispiel gibt es eine Szene, da trifft sich die Obermagierin mit einem ihrer ehemaligen Schülerinnen mitten im Wald.
Einfach so random mitten im Wald, so nach dem Motto, ah, das ist der Feind, was mache ich jetzt?
Ich treffe mich mit dem Feind allein mitten im Wald. Warum?
Ja, es ist, ja, explosive Sachen stehen offen rum.
Zum Beispiel kriegt man am Anfang in einer der ersten Folgen auch erzählt, dass, ja, das stimmt, er lässt auch noch die Rüstung liegen, das stimmt.
In der ersten Folge kriegt man ein bisschen, dass das Magiesystem von Witcher erzählt,
wobei wir alle wissen, das Magiesystem in Witcher gibt es kein Magiesystem, sondern die Magie in The Witcher macht das, was die Story gerade braucht.
Allerdings versuchen sie einem am Anfang zu erklären, ne, die Serie ist nicht schlecht,
das ist aber nicht der große Hype, der darum gemacht wird, wehrt meiner Meinung nach.
Ist nicht schlecht, sie hat jede Menge cooler Momente, vor allem finde ich das Treffen mit Ciri und Geralt am Ende finde ich echt gut gemacht.
Und auch die Love Story mit Geralt und Yennefer, die sind, die ist weniger nervig, als ich mir das vorgestellt habe.
Und generell muss ich euch ehrlich sagen, die Folgen zwischendurch, so dritte, vierte, fünfte, sechste Folgen, die fand ich richtig gut,
gerade weil sie eben, also vor allem die Sachen, die sie mit Geralt gezeigt haben, das waren einfach so richtig kurze, nice, knackige Stories, ja, fand ich, fand ich nicht schlecht.
Die Witcher Serie ist extrem gehypt gewesen, die ist so weit gehypt, dass Elon Musk sogar auf Twitter geschrieben hat, dass man die jetzt in seinem Tesla gucken kann oder sowas.
Zumindest kriegt man am Anfang ein bisschen, versuchen sie einem ein bisschen, das Magiesystem zu erklären von Witcher und sagen so nach dem Motto,
wenn man zaubert, muss man halt immer was opfern dafür. Also da zeigen sie einem, das ist jetzt kein großer Spoiler, sie zeigen einem halt, sie nehmen eine Blume in die eine Hand und zaubern was mit der anderen Hand, dann verwelkt die Blume.
Okay, das ist ein Magiesystem, kann ich mit leben, finde ich sogar ganz gut, ja, erinnert mich ein bisschen an, falls es jemand geguckt hat, einer der wenigen Animes, die ich geguckt habe, Fullmetal Alchemist, da war das ähnlich,
da musstest du auch quasi immer irgendwas opfern, um zaubern zu können und es hat mich da ein bisschen so dran erinnert von dem Magiesystem her und das zeigen sie uns und ergibt Sinn,
aber danach in der Story, danach in der Story wird gezaubert, was das Zeug hält ohne jeglichen Einsatz.
So, man baut erst was auf und erklärt, so funktioniert es, um danach zu sagen, ach nee, nee, nee, also so funktioniert es jetzt doch nicht.
Es ist halt sehr, es passieren, in der Witcher Fernsehserie, es passieren sehr viele Sachen, weil sie einfach nützlich sind für die Story jetzt, weil sie hier und jetzt nützlich sind für die Story, nicht weil sie irgendwie hinpassen würden.
Auch die Entfernungen in der Serie passen überhaupt nicht, ja, es ist kein großer Spoiler, wenn ich sage, dass sich Geralt und Ciri irgendwann treffen in der letzten Folge,
weil das ganze Ding baut darauf auf und ich meine, wer das Spiel gespielt hat, weiß auch, dass Ciri und Geralt sich kennen.
Die Entfernungen passen halt auch überhaupt nicht.
Ciri rennt die komplette Serie durch die Weltgeschichte, ist quasi ein Stück von der Küste zu Skellige weg und auf einmal ist Geralt und Ciri dann in der gleichen Region, obwohl er eigentlich nur ein bisschen mit dem Pferdewagen gezogen wurde.
Es ist sehr convenient, so was da passiert, ja, es ist sehr, es ist jetzt nützlich für die Story, was passiert, ob es Sinn ergibt oder nicht.
Choose my name, es kann durchaus sein, aber das zählt für mich nicht.
Es kann ja nämlich nicht sein, dass man ein Buch, die Bücher lesen muss, um die Sache zu verstehen und außerdem ist es die Aufgabe der Serie, das ordentlich zu erklären
und viele Leute, was ich auf Twitter gelesen habe, sagen ja auch, das macht in der Serie wenig Sinn, weil sich zum Beispiel in den Büchern Ciri und Geralt schon längst kannten, bevor sie sich treffen dort, wo sie sich in der Serie treffen.
Das heißt, die ganzen Ereignisse, wie sie in der Serie sind, ergibt es so direkt, geben die weniger Sinn.
Es öffnen sich zufälligerweise, wenn Geralt vorbeiläuft, mal Geheimtüren und sowas.
Aber was für mich die größte Logiklücke in der Witcher Serie ist, die überhaupt keinen Sinn ergibt, ich sage euch jetzt nicht wo und wann, aber es gibt einen Zauberer, der hat ziemliche Probleme, sich gegen Angreifer zu wehren.
So und ein paar Folgen später macht dieser Zauberer einfach mal ein Portal auf und verschwindet, weil es für die Story gerade nützlich ist, dass er sich an diesen Ort teleportiert.
Dann fragt man sich doch, ok, warum hat er sich nicht einfach ein paar Folgen vorher auch teleportiert, weil er das doch so easy kann und solche Dinge.
Das mag sein, dass es für alles irgendwie um 5 Ecken eine Erklärung gibt, aber das ist einfach faul. Das habe ich jetzt schon ein paar Mal gesagt.
Das ist einfach faul geschrieben, sowas. Das stößt mir auch echt immer sauer auf, weil ich mir denke, ok, man macht das jetzt einzig und allein nur, weil es gerade für die Story wichtig ist, dass der eine Charakter dahin kommt.
An sich hatte die Serie auch coole Sachen, ja, aber es waren halt viele Sachen dabei, wo ich mir gedacht habe, ok, da hätten sie sich mehr Mühe geben können.
Ich muss sagen, unterm Strich würde ich nicht sagen, dass die Serie ein Reinfall ist oder ich würde sogar sagen, die Serie ist ganz gut.
Geralt ist super besetzt. Manchmal hatte ich den Eindruck, sie haben ihm nicht so genau erklärt, was in dieser Szene eigentlich passiert, aber an sich ist Geralt super besetzt.
Ich muss euch sagen, ich finde Serie auch gut besetzt. Gut, Triss habe ich mir ein bisschen anders vorgestellt, aber gut, Yennefer ist gut besetzt. Vor allem der Anfang macht die das echt gut.
Es ist auch witzig, dass auf einmal Charaktere über Nacht Sachen gelernt haben, die sie jetzt brauchen zum Beispiel.
Yennefer ist in der ganzen Serie keine gute Kämpferin irgendwie. Die kann Zaubern, ja, und owned die Leute mit Zaubern, aber so Melee Combat ist Yennefer nicht so pro drin.
Was ja auch klar ist, weil als Zauberer hat man relativ wenig, es gilt man relativ wenig Dual-Wield und sowas.
Bei Geralt sieht es anders aus. Und da gibt es irgendwann eine Szene, da schnappt sich Yennefer einfach zwei Schwerter und Dual-Wieldet wild durch die Gegner.
Alles Kampf erprobt die Gegner und da kommt eine Zauberin, die nicht zaubert und Dual-Wieldet sich einfach da wild einen ab, wo ich mir gedacht habe, Moment, warum kann Yennefer auf einmal krassen Dual-Wield und davor konnte die sich nicht mal wehren gegen den Typ, der sie angegriffen hat.
Da fragt man sich auch so, okay, ist jetzt halt gerade praktisch für die Story. Sinn ergibt es nicht. Was hältst du von den Action-Szenen?
Zweckmäßig, zweckmäßig. Also die große Schlacht, die es dann am Ende gibt, fand ich ziemlich mies und auch wieder sehr, sehr unsinnig, ja, wie da Leute agieren.
Über Nacht umgeskillt, ja, Respekt. Yennefer Respekt. Ansonsten muss ich sagen, waren die Action-Szenen im Großteil okay. Manche CGI ist grausam schlecht gewesen.
Es geht, es geht. Ich muss euch sagen, das große Highlight für mich, leider war da in den letzten Folgen nicht mal so viel drin, das Highlight für mich in dieser Serie ganz klar und das hat auch richtig Spaß gemacht anzugucken.
Ich hätte mir fast gewünscht, sie hätten in der ersten Staffel weniger Ciri und weniger Yennefer gezeigt. Das Beste und das war richtig gut an der Serie,
war die ganzen Story-Abschnitte, wo Dandelion und Geralt einfach durch die Weltgeschichte gestalzt sind und irgendwelche Aufträge erledigt haben und einfach am Start waren.
Das waren eigentlich die besten Folgen, dass Geralt die ganze Zeit Fuck sagt. Das war gut.
Generell muss ich sagen, für mich ist eigentlich neben Geralt, ich finde, die haben Dandelion echt gut getroffen. Genauso würde ich mir den Schwätzer Bade schlechthin vorstellen.
Genauso, den haben sie wirklich gut getroffen. Und die Kurzgeschichten-Umsetzungen sind auch ganz gut. Ich kenne auch nur den ersten Kurzgeschichten-Band.
Also ein paar Sachen, dass die Folge mit der Striege hat man wiedererkannt, das mit dem Djinn hat man wiedererkannt. Was war denn sonst noch? Also ein paar Sachen hat man wiedererkannt, die waren auch ganz gut gemacht.
Hatten mit der Vorlage teilweise relativ wenig zu tun, aber waren gut umgesetzt. Und generell die Kombination in den Folgen, wo einfach nur Geralt und Dandelion unterwegs waren und haben irgendwelche Witcher-Aufträge erledigt, die fand ich eigentlich am besten.
Doch, doch. O-M-G in small, haben sie. Am Anfang, doch, doch. Ich meine, Geralt rettet Dandelion am Ende dann sogar. Also doch, schon. Am Anfang hatte er halt keinen Bock auf ihn gehabt, was ich auch verstehen kann.
Ich meine, der hatte den einfach nur voll getextet. Am Ende rettet er ihn ja sogar noch und man merkt schon, dass das sein Freund ist. Er scheißt sie dann am Ende mal ein bisschen an, okay. Aber ich finde, insgesamt haben sie das ganz gut gemacht.
Leider ist so die, so insgesamt halt, es wird halt, so dieser, es hat viele, viele Stellen, die sind cool und die machen auch echt Spaß zu gucken. Aber so im Großen und Ganzen, muss ich sagen, hätte man das deutlich besser umsetzen können.
Und, also wenn ich, wenn ich mal so eine Prozentwertung abgeben müsste für das Gesamte, also manche Folgen hätte ich ohne Probleme 85, 90 Prozent gegeben. Nämlich gerade Folgen, wo halt zum größten Teil einfach Geralt, Dandelion am Start sind Witcher-Aufträge erledigen.
Die 95, 98 Prozent, die waren teilweise echt cool, aber das war halt zeitlich von der Gesamtserie jetzt nicht so viel. Also wenn ich, wenn ich sagen müsste, so insgesamt, was ich der Serie geben würde, nachdem sie schon ein paar richtig coole Sachen dabei hatte, aber auch vieles fragwürdige und, und, und, und, Dinge, wo ich das Gefühl hatte, sie, sie wussten nicht so richtig, wie sie das, wie sie das Ganze machen sollen, dass es von der Story funktioniert, würde ich sagen so 60, 65, 65 Prozent würde ich der Serie geben.
Also nicht total mies, aber jetzt auch nichts, was irgendwie den großen Hype rechtfertigen würde. So 60, 65, 65 Prozent würde ich der Serie vielleicht geben, aber auch nur dank der coolen Momente, die es zwischendurch gab.
Es, es ist halt einfach zu viel aus meinem Geschmack aus, aus Nützlichkeit passiert für die Story. Geralt muss dorthin. Hm, ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn, der ist grad ganz woanders. Ja, dann passiert jetzt mal was komplett unlogisches, dass Geralt halt dahin kommt.
Als je Dinger. Äh, Terox, dankeschön, vier Monate, huge. Äh, es gab noch ein paar Fragen, hast du eine Idee, weswegen sich ein Internetadapter alle paar Minuten trennt und wieder verbindet?
Äh, soll ich sagen, kaputt, weiter Switch-Port-Probleme, vielleicht ist das Kabel im Arsch, vielleicht kann alles sein, vielleicht spackt der Windows-Treiber rum. Gute mal mit einer Linux Live-CD und gucke, ob das dann auch immer noch der Fall ist. Oder Linux Live-CD, alter, keck weh, mit dem Live-USB-Stick.
Ja, Prime 1096, das ist auch so was, hab ich ja grad gesagt. Sie etablieren das erstmal so, dass du zum Zaubern im Witcher-Universum quasi was einsetzen musst und dann kannst du einfach random zaubern, ohne was, ohne was, es ist halt.
Äh, was, dieses Video zum Thema Open World spricht die Ubisoft-Formel ganz gut an. Vielleicht kannst du das als nächstes gucken. Äh, oh, nee, nein, nein, nein. David Hain kann ich mir nicht angucken. Kann ich nicht, kann ich mir nicht angucken, nee. Ist echt nicht mein Fall.
Ähm, Action-Szene der Serie, hab ich schon was zu gesagt, halt zweckmäßig. Okay, guck mal weiter, wir waren ja immer noch nicht fertig mit dem Video. Ach so, genau, was wollten wir jetzt eigentlich gucken? Ähm, Moment, wir hatten doch mit irgendwas angefangen zu gucken, oder? Ah, hier, Top Open World Games.
Haha, huge, huge, skill-Style werfen. What?
Okay, das ist für alle Dragonball-Fans.
Dragonball ist auch so richtig braindead von der Story her. Ich habe die letzte Serie auch geguckt und ich fand sie nicht schlecht für das, was sie sein soll, einfach sinnlose Action-Kram und auch das Ende war cool, aber Dragonball-Story ist halt echt huge-braindead.
Ich meine, für alle Dragonball-Fans mag das, mag das, äh, das ist mittlerweile übrigens raus schon und ich hab nen Test gelesen, dass, ähm, die Open World halt voll von Arsch ist.
Dass du halt massig, massig Fetch-Quests und, ähm, Collect-Fetch-Quests und Sammel-Quests als Bekriegiger hast und die Open World kacke ist.
Ihh, das hab ich ja schon voll verdrängt, es kommt neues Watch Dogs raus. Hat das, hat das die Welt wirklich gebraucht?
Das erste Watch Dogs fand ich ganz okay. Das hat, das hat halt schon nicht diesem ganzen Hype standgehalten.
Ähm, das zweite war unsinniges, unsinnige Hexor-Hipster, die unsinnige Dinger machen und das dritte, weiß ich nicht, hab ich auch gar nichts zugesehen und Stadia. War richtig keck, weh. Mal gucken, ob Stadia bis zu dem Release überhaupt noch gibt.
Ich glaub, das wird so langweilig.
Das wird so langweilig.
Was war denn das nochmal?
Was war denn das nochmal? Da haben wir doch schonmal den Trailer gesehen.
Man sieht halt nichts vom Game, ne?
Der soll mal lieber sein letztes Game of Thrones Buch fertig schreiben, wo die Leute irgendwie schon 10 Jahre drauf warten.
Warcraft 3 kommt, kommt jetzt demnächst?
Oh, das ist das Flötenspiel. Das ist das, wo sie auf der, auf der E3 Flöte gespielt haben. Das ist doch der, oder? Der Flöten-Typ, wo sich alle gefragt haben, warum flöte der uns jetzt 5 Minuten einen vor?
Ich glaub, das wird so langweilig.
Sieht cool aus. Hat ein bisschen, hat wirklich ein bisschen, ähm, es heißt jetzt Creed-Stellts in Japan oder so. Ja, Tribolan. Sieht ähnlich aus.
Ja, gut, das war klar, das musste drin sein.
Mal gucken, ob das wirklich dieses Jahr noch rauskommt.
Ich hätte keine Probleme, wenn wir das noch mehr verschieben. Die sollen das rausbringen, wenn es fertig ist.
Leute, ist das?
Das ist immer noch? Ist das nicht die gleiche Schriftart, wie sie in Witcher auch hatten?
Ah, man erkennt es jetzt nicht wirklich. Nee, ist eine andere, okay.
Wo sind verstehen geblieben, Leute? Ich blick nicht mal durch.
Das sieht schon ziemlich ähnlich aus, die Schriftart. Okay, gucken wir mal, wie sind das?
Oh, oh, es ist, ja, nee, nee, ich glaub nicht, nee, ich glaub nicht, das ist, aber es sieht schon recht ähnlich aus.
Na, ob das noch rauskommt, dieses Jahr, die haben ja so einen riesen Wirbeltraum gemacht.
Ich hab Hunger.
Ja, also wenn Flight Simulator nicht Open World ist, Flight Simulator dürfte so das Open Worldigste sein.
Es ist nämlich die Welt und die ist auch noch Open.
War nicht schon irgendwie geleakt, wo das jetzt spielen wird, das neue Assassin's Creed?
Ah ja, genau.
Scandinavien-Stalls, das fände ich cool. Das könnte mich tatsächlich mal wieder dazu bringen, ein Assassin's Creed zu kaufen.
In Frankfurt nachts am Hauptbahnhof, genau, da wird's spielen.
Übrigens noch ein bisschen Mittelalter Lehrstunde, Skandinavia ist nicht gleich Wikinger und Wikinger ist nicht gleich Skandinavia.
Wikinger waren nur die, die auf Raubzüge gefahren sind.
So, haben wir wieder was gelernt heute.
Okay, how to secure your network.
Da bin ich immer, mal gucken, das könnte sein, dass das übelste Resident Sleeper Video wird.
Aber ich bin mal gespannt, was er erzählt, ob ich da, ob ich der Sache zustimmen würde, was er erzählt.
Max, das hast du letztens schon erzählt.
Ja, es kommt durchaus mal vor, dass ich die ein oder anderen Sachen öfters erzähle im Stream.
Ich merke mir das auch nicht jedes Mal alles hundertprozentig, was ich schon erzählt habe.
Ich mein, Big Brain hin oder her, aber manchmal fällt mir auch Sachen doppelt ein.
Okay, how to secure your network.
So, da bin ich mal gespannt.
Jetzt übertreibt man nicht.
Es ist viel möglich, wenn einer sich im Heimnetzwerk ist.
Aber die meisten Leute werden nicht über ihr Heimnetzwerk angegriffen, sondern weil sie irgendeine Scheiße runterladen.
Und es gibt einen ganz einfachen Trick, wie ihr euer Heimnetzwerk möglichst secure machen könnt.
Einfach Kabel verwenden.
6 Trillionen, das ist Ami-Rechnung, also Billiarden.
Dann haben sie Billion, das ist Milliarde, und ich glaube, Trillion ist dann unsere Billion.
Na einhalten, Leute.
Kokona einhalten.
Aber ich mein, wer das Gewicht von einer Maus noch mit ounces angibt, ist eh nicht mehr ganz bei der Sache.
Ja, also das Knu, das ist ziemlich secure.
Billionen.
Ja, das stimmt.
Das stimmt.
Es gibt auch noch was richtig gut.
Verwendet Kabel.
Verwendet einfach Kabel.
Und ich kann ein bisschen Sachen nebenbei erzählen.
Also eine Sache, ich weiß nicht, ob er dazu was gleich noch sagen wird.
Strong Password.
Ein starkes Passwort ist entgegen der allgemeinen Auffassung nicht unbedingt immer ein Passwort, was Groß-Kleinschreibung, Sonderzeichen und Zahlen enthält.
Das wichtigste bei einem Passwort ist die Länge.
Das kann auch dann ein relativ simples Passwort sein.
Hauptsache, es ist lang.
Wenn das Passwort lang ist, habt ihr eigentlich schon gewonnen.
Und dann ist besser, ihr nehmt ein langes Passwort, was ihr euch gut merken könnt, als ein nicht ganz so langes Passwort, was so kryptisch ist, dass ihr keine Ahnung mehr nach dem Tag habt oder ihr schon instant nicht mehr was es eigentlich ist.
Also es spricht überhaupt nichts dagegen, dass ihr als WLAN-Passwort sowas nehmt wie...
Wubblors hat den besten Chat auf ganz Twitch.
So nach dem Motto.
Das ist schön lang und das hexert euch keiner.
Also mein Lieblingspasswort wisst ihr immer 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Aber es wäre einfach für WLAN-Geschichten ein...
Und das sein.
Router.
Ich finde die Aussprache von ihm cool.
Das ist so ein Zwischending zwischen Router und Cisco.
Das ist so, der sagt Router, sagt er irgendwie.
Ich finde nicht...
Rauders.
Radars.
Radar.
Oh!
Eine nachgebaute Windows-Konsole hier.
Pock.
Jetzt kommt ja die CMD-Hacks.
Vor allem...
Vor allem 999.
Ganz genau.
So sieht es aus.
Das stimmt, da hat er recht.
Ja.
Da hat er recht.
Da würde ich auch unterschiedliche Sachen nehmen.
Es geht mir nicht mehr ab.
Oh Mann.
Ja.
Das stimmt, da hat er recht.
WPA2.
Ganz ehrlich, es gibt keine aktuellen Router bzw. Access Point, die kein WPA2 können.
Also fällt mir keiner ein.
WP ist für den Arsch.
Es ist WPA2 noch und ich weiß es nicht, bin ich nicht obaktuell entstanden.
Also das, wie gesagt, das wichtigste ist ein langes Passwort.
Dass da Nummern und Sonderzeichen drin sind ist ein Bonus, aber das wichtigste ist ein langes Passwort.
Ihr könnt auch einfach das Leerzeichen ersetzen.
Durch einen Dollar oder sowas.
Also wie gesagt, wenn ihr sowas denn hier...
Max hat den besten Chat auf ganz Twitch und dann macht er einfach anstatt zum Leerzeichen...
Hauptsache es ist lang.
Ich meine, ihr könnt natürlich auch die Profi-Variante machen.
Also am allersichersten ist natürlich, ihr lasst euch ein langes Passwort generieren.
Und speichert das dann in irgendeinem Passport Manager.
Die Sache ist bloß die, ihr werdet früher oder später mal auf einem Handy eintippen müssen.
Und dann bietet es sich an, wenn es was ist, was man gut schreiben kann.
Und nicht 40 Zeichen random Bullshit sind.
BuzzTVE, bei uns gibt es sogar noch offene WLANs.
Weiß ich, was die Leute so treiben.
Ein offenes WLAN bei uns heißt SonyTV.
Ich frage mich, ob Sony Fernseher WLAN aufmachen können.
Oder ob der einen WLAN aufgemacht hat für seinen Sony Fernseher.
Das kann man machen, aber ich ändere die SSID eh immer.
Allein schon, dass ich irgendwas habe, was ich mir gut merken kann.
Weil bei uns gibt es hier in der Nachbarschaft, gibt es keine Ahnung.
20 Fritzboxen, 20 Unity Media Modem.
Das ist noch wenig, wenn ihr nicht merkt, was davon jetzt meins ist.
Wir stellen das einfach um, wenn irgendwas fast passt und gut ist.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Übrigens, wisst ihr was noch viel besser ist?
Anstatt nur ein anderes Passwort zu vergeben.
Es ist viel besser, einfach das Admin Interface nicht vom WLAN aus zugreifbar zu machen.
Weil warum muss das Router Admin Interface vom WLAN aus zugreifbar sein?
Es ist total unsinnig.
Ja, das ist übrigens echt okay.
Also ich würde euch einmal empfehlen, speichert es in einem Passwort-Save.
So ein Key-Pass oder sowas.
Aber es ist definitiv nicht verkehrt, das Passwort aufzuschreiben und irgendwo hin zu legen.
Weil das Passwort wird dadurch nicht wirklich unsicherer.
Es muss jemand physisch in eurem Haus sein und den Zettel finden, dass er das Passwort rauskriegt.
Also sprich, es muss erstmal jemand in die Wohnung rein bei euch.
Und das ist ja in den selbsten Fällen der Fall.
Passwörter aufschreiben ist viel besser als man denkt.
Es ist viel besser als in einer Plain Text Datei auf dem Desktop Passwort TXT die Passwörter hinzulegen.
So dieser Medienwechsel von Rechner auf Papier, das bringt halt keiner.
Selbst wenn einer bei euch auf dem Rechner was drauf hat, der wird keinen Zugriff dadurch auf euren Passwortzettel kriegen.
Und meistens sind die Leute, die einbrechen, nicht die, die sich für Passwörter interessieren.
Die wollen dann euer Geld klauen, Schmuck klauen, was auch immer klauen, aber nicht euren Passwortzettel.
Das Ding hatte ich auch früher.
So einen hässlichen TP Link Access Point.
Für 15 Euro oder so.
Der funktioniert theoretisch schon immer noch, aber ist halt ziemlich outdated.
TP Link, ja.
Was?
Die Aussprache muss ich mir nochmal anhören, wartet mal.
Ich hab auch keine Ahnung, wie man das aussprechen soll, aber das soll Gui Firewall heißen, wahrscheinlich.
Ja, der hat aber prinzipiell recht, das ist wirklich nicht verkehrt.
Das ist ziemlich einfach, einschalten und gut ist.
IP Tables kann man keinem Noob zubuten, da irgendwas von der Hand zu machen.
Aber das Beste ist einfach auf dem Rechner keine Pots aufmachen und vor allem nicht weiterleiten aus dem Internet.
Aber wer macht sowas schon?
Der PF Sense spricht da wahrscheinlich auch.
Pff, wo sind sie?
Ja, das kann man machen, aber brauchen ist fragwürdig, ob man das unbedingt haben muss.
Also Webbrowsing auf dem Desktop ist definitiv, also so ein normales Windows mit Browser drauf ist definitiv nicht sicherer als über ein Smartphone.
Auf dem Windows Desktop, auch wenn es die letzten Jahre deutlich sicherer geworden ist, fängst du dir immer noch tausendmal einfacher irgendeinen Scheiß im Internet ein, wie auf deinem Smartphone.
Da hat er recht, die meisten VPNs sind für'n Arsch, habe ich ein extra Video zugemacht.
Ja, was, die WE, was blockt es denn so Schlimmes?
Warum?
Wozu sollte ich Tor standardmäßig verwenden, warum?
Das ist total bescheuert.
Warum? Es ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn standardmäßig Tor zu verwenden.
Ja, das kann man tatsächlich machen, das mache ich aber nicht mehr, weil es mir zu sehr auf den Sack geht.
Kann man machen, kann man machen, ist das irgendwie ein Tutorial für Paranoide, denn auch nicht mal, es macht es ja sogar unsicherer, wenn du standardmäßig alles über Tor machst.
Ja, kann man machen, heitet aber nicht wirklich.
Ja, kann man machen, ist nicht so wahnsinnig effektiv.
Ich habe keine SSID versteckt.
Okay, Basti.
Das bringt doch überhaupt nichts.
Also die Gateway IP Adresse zu ändern ist ja wirklich sehr, mir fällt es schwer, das sogar Security to Obscurity zu nennen, das ist weder noch.
Mein Router hat auch keine Eins hinten, aber einfach, weil ich mit anderen besser merken kann, also andere Sachen an die Eins stelle, die ich mir merken muss.
Mein Router hat glaube ich die 60, ob 60 hat er.
Ja, das stimmt, da hat er wieder recht.
Ja, das ist wirklich nicht verkehrt.
Das ist echt nicht verkehrt.
Kann man machen, aber die meisten Seiten, die HTTPS beziehungsweise TLS anbieten, leiten dich ja automatisch schon um, aber das kann man machen.
Was er jetzt damit zu tun hat, weiß man auch nicht so genau.
Ja, das ist echt nicht verkehrt.
Google DNS Beste.
Das kann man machen.
Ich verwende mittlerweile entweder die Standard Google, also die Google DNS oder Cloudflare.
Ja, mach ich auch, easy killer.
Und mir gibt es die DNS per IP, per DHCP. Und der DNS hat dann halt als Upstream Cloudflare und Google drinne.
Das kann man machen, das ist tatsächlich nicht verkehrt.
Leider, leider, leider funktioniert es nicht mehr für YouTube und Twitch richtig.
Kona lernt.
Ja, das stimmt, da hat er recht.
Tribolon, das sind zwei komplett unterschiedliche Sachen. Pihol macht ja rein DNS-Filter und Uplog kann er den Content der Seite lesen und entfernen.
Das heißt, Uplog funktioniert auf YouTube und Twitch und Pihol funktioniert nicht auf YouTube und Twitch, weil YouTube und Twitch mittlerweile die Werbung von dem gleichen Server bereitstellt wie das Video.
Das ist das einzige, was wirklich richtig hilft.
Wenn man wirklich auf Nummer sicher gehen will, dann stöpselt man die wichtigen internen Systeme an Netzwerk an und hat ein zweites Netz für WLAN, was man auch so sicher macht wie möglich, aber selbst wenn was passiert, man keinen Zugriff auf interne Sachen hat.
Ja, easykiller, ich habe leider noch nichts gefunden, was Twitch Ads und YouTube Ads auf iOS ordentlich blocken kann.
Auf Android ist kein Problem, wobei einen richtig guten Twitch Client gibt es für Android auch nicht, außer den offiziellen und YouTube ist kein Problem und auf iOS kannst du halt eh vergessen.
Also ich trage es fertig.
Jetzt, jetzt komme die Hexor an Start, äh.
Kleinen Rotti Extra verwende ich auch auf Android, aber wirklich gefallen tut es mir nicht.
Machen sie aber hier auf richtig, äh, der Hexor Mode Activated.
Aber machen.
Waren schon ein paar sinnvolle Sachen drinne, aber vieles ist nicht wirklich.
Also IP ändern, ich weiß nicht.
Okay, avoid doing the following on Linux.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Rm-rf-slash zum Beispiel sollte man nicht machen.
Sollte auch keine Forkbomb ausführen.
Ja, da hat er recht, aber wer kennt nicht Curl XY Pipe nach Bash? Hat jeder schon mal gemacht? Sollte man natürlich nicht machen.
Moment, zeigt er auch irgendwas?
Ah, okay, also lesen wir es mal durch, was er vorschlägt, da müssen wir das Video nicht gucken.
Ja, auch klar.
Ja, ja. Ja, okay, aber macht man trotzdem, weil man faul ist.
Das stimmt, wobei ich meistens vorher schon weiß, ob es notwendig ist, Sachen recursively zu machen oder nicht.
Oh, das mache ich laufend. Ich bin öfters mal auf meinem System unterwegs und passe irgendwas an, was nicht in Home ist.
Don't worry if something breaks, das ist wohl wahr. Das passiert öfters als man will.
Raspberry Pi 4 case, das muss ich mir jetzt mal angucken, weil ich brauche eins, der wird zu heiß.
Wenn ich ihn benutze, ich verwende ihn meistens nicht. Aber wenn ich ihn benutze, wird er zu heiß.
Wir haben es ja mal ausprobiert. Was hatten wir on stream? 90 Grad, 95 Grad oder so?
Es war auf jeden Fall heiß. Er hat ja sogar runtergetaktet dann.
Wartet mal Leute, wird das überhaupt lauter hier, wenn ich hier lauter mache?
Moment, hatte ich mir nicht so einen Case gekauft?
Ich habe einen Raspberry Pi noch nie übertaktet.
Ich habe mir dieses Gehäuse hier bestellt, aber ich glaube das sackt.
Das hier hatte ich mir bestellt, aber ich glaube das ist Crap.
Ich glaube das sackt. Es hat auch noch einen Lüfter oben drauf, aber das bleibt dann auf jeden Fall kühl.
Ich habe die Tastatur nicht mehr. Bei der Gelegenheit könnte ich dieses komische Corsair Zeug mal runter schmeißen.
Das sieht aus wie ein Alienware Gehäuse für ein Raspberry Pi, finde ich auch.
Es könnte irgendein Alienware Ding sein.
Danke schön.
Es wäre viel geiler, wenn man diesen Lüfter dann auch noch an den Raspberry Pi an die GPIOs anschließen könnte, dass der Raspberry Pi seinen eigenen Lüfter steuern kann.
Das ist cool, dass sie einen GPIO Header Ausgang haben.
Das ist doof.
Es ist quasi so eine Riser-Karte für einen Raspberry Pi.
Da weiß ich nicht, also das gefällt mir nicht.
Also es wäre schön, wenn die Ausgänge so wären, dass es so bleiben könnte wie es standardmäßig ist.
Dann noch so eine Karte dazwischen stecken gefällt mir nicht.
Erstmal Raspberry Pi CPU Köpfen und Flüssigmetall drauf machen.
Push, push, push.
Das sieht aber aus als sitzt das wirklich sehr stabil.
Sagt man, diese Seite vom Gehäuse hier ist doch komplett überflüssig, oder?
Man hätte doch einfach das Gehäuse hier aufhören lassen können und die Raspberry Pi Anschlüsse hier Löcher für rein machen können.
Ansonsten ist hier doch nichts.
Da wäre das auch noch ein bisschen kleiner.
Ja, das stimmt.
Der Raspberry Pi als Desktop Ersatz ist total hängen geblieben.
Ich habe meinen Raspberry noch ernsthaft noch nie im Leben übertaktet.
Ich wusste, dass es geht und es geht sogar relativ einfach.
Ich habe noch nie dran gedacht, ehrlich gesagt.
Die Grafiker übertaktet.
Das ist ja richtig Raytracing.
Also ich tippe mal drauf, dass es am Ende irgendwie 55 Grad hat oder so.
Weil ich meine, es hat einen aktiven Lüfter drauf.
Oder hatte es einen? Ja doch, es hat einen Lüfter. 55 Grad.
4 GB RAM, ja. Die neuen haben bis zu 4 GB.
Ich habe ja auch mal 4 GB bestellt, gleich als der released wurde.
Und mache damit nichts, der steht einfach nur sinnlos rum.
Ich tippe mal 55 Grad, weil der hat einen Lüfter, wenn der angeht.
Das dauert nicht mehr lang, dann gibt es wirklich Raspberry Pi Wasserkühlung oder Stickstoff.
Also wenn jetzt der Lüfter angeht, dann wird das nicht mal viel höher.
Aber es gibt schon echte Wasserkühlung von Raspberry. Wirklich? Warum?
Ich meine, schick ist es. Schick ist das Gehäuse, kann man nichts sagen.
Ich finde es blöd, dass es so eine Zwischenkarte braucht.
Aber okay. Es ist auf jeden Fall schon mal ein ordentliches Raspberry Gehäuse im Vergleich zum...
Weil das offizielle Case ist halt crap.
Gerade beim Vierer, der so warm wird, ist Müll das offizielle Gehäuse.
Das hat mir noch nie gefallen, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber du hast bisher auch nichts gebraucht an Kühlung, großartig.
Meine Raspberries stehen zum größten Teil offen rum, ohne Case, ohne alles.
Daumen halt ein bisschen vor sich hin.
Auf dem 3D-Drucker oben auch steht eins ohne Gehäuse.
Was ist das? Mekko S.
Das ist zu harte Cost, das gucken wir uns jetzt hier nicht an.
Drei neue Level durchgespielt. Doom Eternal ist krass anders.
Okay, wer hat diesen Titel bei der GameStar wieder gemacht?
Du, ja klar.
Normalerweise müsste jetzt noch viel mehr Mii schreiben, dass das funktioniert.
Aber der Twitch-Chat ist noch nicht so wach heute.
BigBrain.
Weine zu Temtem haben wir nicht gespielt.
Oh, ein Film.
Der Multiplayer war scheiße, der war richtig räudig.
Die Ausgangssituation ist mal ganz grob gesagt, ohne dass ich zu viel vorausgreife.
Die Erde ist von den Dämonen überrannt worden.
Die Grundaussage, man hat es ja auch schon im Trailer gesehen, da sieht es gar nicht gut aus.
Wer soll es jetzt richten? Der Doom Slayer.
Wir sind wieder als der Doom Slayer am Start und zerlegen da jede Menge Dämonen.
Die Besonderheit ist aber, dass wir da nicht bleiben auf der Erde, sondern dass es deutlich mehr Schauplätze geben wird.
Wir haben in den letzten drei Levels jetzt schon gemerkt, dass da schon viel mehr Abwechslungen drinsteckt als in Doom 2016,
wo wir im Endeffekt ja nur die UAC Basis auf dem Mars hatten und die Hölle und sehr viel mehr war da irgendwie nicht.
Es sind sehr viele neue spannende Locations und auch spannende NPCs bzw. Fraktionen mit dabei.
Es hat ja auch eine etwas andere Struktur als der Vorgänger, denn es gibt jetzt so eine Art Hub-Welt.
Wie funktioniert das?
Das hat mich überrascht, weil damit hätte ich mich gerechnet. Ich dachte, das wäre wieder eine legale Abfolge von Leveln.
In diese Basis kehrt der Slayer immer wieder zurück und die erfüllt eine Reihe von Zwecken.
Das Grundsätzliche ist, dass es ein leichter Weg ist oder ein leichtes Mittel ist für die Entwickler, den Doom Slayer an verschiedene Orte zu schicken,
weil du kannst ihn ja schlecht jahrhundertelang mit dem Raumschiff irgendwie rumfliegen lassen.
Das heißt, er hat da ein Portal und da startest du die nächste Mission.
Das heißt, da gehst du dann in neue Welten. Das heißt, das ist ein super einfacher Weg, um diese neuen Übungen auch erreichbar zu machen aus Story-Perspektive.
Und zum anderen ist es auch ein Ort, wo viel von der Lore stattfindet.
Das hatten sie in Borderlands 3 mit dem Raumschiff auch.
Oder von der Story, auf die in Doom Eternal mehr Wert gelegt wird.
Also es findet einfach mehr Storytelling per se schon statt in Form von Zwischensequenzen, auch in Form von NPCs, auf die man trifft,
aber auch mehr Story im Sinne von Lore, dass man mehr über die Hintergründe erfährt.
Man erfährt sogar, wo eigentlich der Doom Slayer herkommt.
Ich wollte schon immer mehr Doom Lore.
Ich meine, es ist nicht verkehrt. Die Reihe ist halt bisher immer auch eine großartige Story ausgekommen.
Es kann man sehr viel Audiologs nachlesen.
Oh, Audiologs.
Und der Doom Slayer hat auch so ein bisschen sein Man Cave, wo er dann Beute hortet und kleine Collectibles hortet und so.
Spricht der denn diesmal?
Nein, der spricht nicht und er gibt sich auch genauso, wie man ihn aus Doom 2016 kennt.
Also kompromisslos, brutal und relativ straightforward, sag ich mal.
Doom 2016 hatte ja auch so ein bisschen eine humoristische Seite, fand ich, z.B. in Zwischensequenzen.
Genau.
Ist das immer noch dabei oder ist es ernster geworden?
Es ist sogar, glaube ich, ein bisschen, ich sage jetzt mal in Anführungszeichen, witziger.
Sie haben jetzt nicht irgendwie auf Slapstick durch die Bank irgendwie gewechselt,
aber es sind einfach ein paar Szenen drin, wo ich wirklich lachen musste, die wirklich sehr gut da reinpassen auch in das Ganze.
Und ja, also die Amerikaner sagen ja immer so dieses Tongue-in-Cheek, dass sie die Story und diese Lore nicht komplett 100% bierernst.
Da sind auch Sachen drin, wo man sich denkt, das ist halt so ein Kontakt.
Also es wäre auch verdammt schwer geworden, bei Doom was zu machen, was wirklich ernst ist, ne?
Entweder sind es der Mond auf dem Mars, der Mond auf der Erde, der Mond auf dem Mond, irgendwo der Mond.
Das ist ein Partoon-mäßiges Ding, da sind viele Bezüge drin zu He-Man, also Masters of the Universe und so.
Und das passt erstaunlich gut zusammen.
Also es fühlt sich alles relativ stimmig.
Du hast mir gesagt, es gäbe eine Dreifach-Taktik, eine neue, was genau ist damit gemeint?
Auch was, was mich beim Spielen überrascht hat, die Kämpfe sind deutlich taktischer.
Und ich sage jetzt, taktischer muss ich...
War das gerade Doomfist-Move? Habt ihr das gesehen? Doomfist-Move? Guckt mal.
Die Kämpfe sind deutlich taktischer.
Der springt hier runter und dann macht er hier so einen komischen...
Ach nee, nee, nee, nee, er klettert, er klettert hoch, er klettert hoch.
Das sah für mich aus, als hätte er so einen Doomfist-Sprung gemacht.
Was ja zu Doom auch passen würde.
Das muss ich vorwegschicken, das muss man bewusst einklammern.
Es ist nicht so, dass Doom ein Taktik-Shooter wird in Eternal.
Es ist immer noch genauso schnell und genauso linear die Kämpfe, wie sie waren.
Vielleicht sogar noch ein bisschen schneller.
Aber es gibt drei Komponenten in den Kämpfen, die jetzt deutlicher zum Tragen kommen als in Doom 2016.
Und zwar ist es das Ressourcen-Management. Du hast Munition, du hast Rüstung und du hast Health.
Und diesen drei Ressourcen kämpfst du.
Das ist eigentlich das, was Doom schon seit den 90ern ausmacht, diese drei Ressourcen in den Kämpfen.
Und der Unterschied zu Doom 2016 ist jetzt, wie du da rankommst.
Die Health-Pickups oder generell Pickups auch von Rüstung und Munition in den Leveln sind deutlich weniger.
Das heißt, damit wirst du nicht hinkommen.
Und da kommt dann diese Dreifach-Taktik ins Spiel.
Nämlich du hast die Kettensäge als Nahkampfoption, um Gegner schnell zu exekutieren.
Dann werfen sie Munition ab und zwar für alle Waffen.
Du hast die Möglichkeit dieser Glory-Kills.
Das heißt, wenn die Dämonen geschwächt sind und leuchten, gehst du hin, dann macht er diese sehr brutalen Animationen.
Das war ja so eine Sache, die fand ich im Letzten schon doof.
Diese Zwischen-Animationen, die fand ich im Letzten ja schon doof.
Und die haben sie ja schon beschleunigt in der Entwicklung.
Die waren ja ursprünglich noch länger.
Und du musstest das im Letzten auch schon machen, weil die Gegner mehr getroppt haben, wenn du sie findest, anstatt einfach zu killen.
Wenn du gerade Lebenspunkte brauchst und der dritte Faktor ist ganz neu.
Du hast diesen Schultermontierten Flammenwerfer jetzt, den du einfach auf Knopfdruck dann abfeuerst.
Und wenn die Dämonen brennen, dann lassen sie Rüstung fallen.
Das heißt, hast du wenig Rüstung, versuchst du die Dämonen erstmal im Brand zu stecken.
Und das macht die Kämpfe in Anführungszeichen wie gesagt taktischer, weil du jetzt überlegst, okay, was brauche ich gerade.
Huge big brain tactics.
Und irgendwann hat sich daraus ein super guter Flow entwickelt, als ich selber gespielt habe.
Und ich habe mich dann teilweise dabei erwischt, wie ich an einem Zombie vorbeigerannt bin.
Der dann noch so, hier bin ich, hallo.
Und dann habe ich gedacht, nein, dich hebe ich auf, weil zu dir komme ich nachher gleich nochmal mit der Kettensäge, um Munition zu holen.
Das heißt, du siehst die Gegner auch als Ressource und nicht nur als Gegner.
Das hatten sie ja von Anfang an gesagt, dass die Doom Eternal eher als so in Anführungszeichen ein Puzzle-Shooter sehen.
Und auch diese Verbindung zu den ersten Doom-Spielen tatsächlich von 1993 zurückgehend zu sagen.
Die waren auch über weiter Strecken auch Rätsel-Shooter.
Ja gut, die, das waren die Spiele, also das waren, das war auch Quake und das waren auch die Shooter früher gerne.
Oder auch, guckt euch mal, auch noch Doomcreme 3D an oder so.
Die hatten da diese an, diese, diese merkwürdige Level-Design von sammle 50 Key-Cards, um, um dann durch irgendeine Tür zu kommen.
Das finde ich war keine großartige Stärke der Spiele von damals.
Ja, Half-Life hat es dann richtig gemacht.
Die haben den ganzen Scheiß weggeschmissen.
Das hatte eine nachvollziehbare, lineare Sache.
Auch wenn du in Half-Life manchmal springen musstest, manchmal ein Knöpfchen drücken musstest, aber das war nachvollziehbar.
Nicht so dieses, okay, wir müssen Key-Cards suchen, damit wir dann irgendeine Tür am anderen Level-Ende, die ich schon längst vergessen habe, wieder aufmachen müssen.
Das war, finde ich, keine Stärke der Spiele damals.
... einen richtigen Weg findet, wie man sich vernünftig durch den Level durcharbeitet, mit den Ressourcen umgeht.
Eine Neuerung gibt es jetzt aber, und die ist wahrscheinlich das streitbarste neue Element in Zusammenhang mit dem Doom als Rätsel-Shooter, nämlich die Jump-&-Run-Passagen. Wie ist dir das jetzt vorgekommen?
Also prinzipiell fand ich es gut, dass es diese neuen Bewegungsmöglichkeiten erstmal gibt.
Also das war tatsächlich was Positives eher daran, weil du jetzt diesen Dash hast, mit dem du dich schnell durch die Luft bewegst und schnell ausweichst.
Du hast ab und zu, die Entwickler nennen sie Monkey-Bars, also so Stangen in der Welt, die interaktiv sind.
Das heißt, dann schwingt er sich... Was halt irgendwie... Muss man mal gucken, wie das funktioniert.
Weil ich hatte schon das Gefühl, dass man in Doom eine recht schwerfällige Bewegung hatte.
Also man ist jetzt nicht geschlichen oder so, man konnte auch ganz gut rumspringen, aber man hatte schon das Gefühl, man hat gemerkt, dass man in einem fetten Anzug drin steckt.
Und das, weiß ich, ob das jetzt so richtig passt.
Und all diese Bewegungs-Sachen fand ich im Kampf super geil. Will ich auch, wenn man zurückgeht zum alten Doom, zum Doom 2016, dann fühlt sich das einfach total langsam an.
Was für eine Kletter-Animation, guckt euch das mal an.
Super geil. Will ich auch, wenn man zurückgeht zum alten Doom, zum Doom 2016...
Jetzt, jetzt, guckt euch die Kletter-Animation mal an.
...16, dann fühlt sich das einfach total langsam an.
Wo es dann aber irgendwie harpert für mich, oder geharpert hat, war, wenn es nur noch auf diese Jump'n'Run-Mechaniken ankommt.
Es gibt Passagen, wo du halt Hindernisse überwindest, und Lava, und runterfallende Packungen...
Big Frank klettert.
...und dann verlangt dir das Spiel ab, dass du alles aneinanderkettest.
Das heißt, da musst du den Doppelsprung, dann dash, dann klettern, dann schwingen...
Das kann gut funktionieren, Leute, das kann... Auch wenn ich dir jetzt ein bisschen stresse, das kann gut funktionieren.
...und dann wieder die Passage von vorne anfangen muss.
Je nachdem wie sie... Das kommt ganz drauf an, wie sie die Levels bauen.
Das kann gut funktionieren, kann auch voll in die Hose gehen.
Alle Zeit direkt wieder aufgestellt, das heißt, es ist nicht ganz so ärgerlich.
Aber in meiner Wahrnehmung nimmt das halt sehr das Pacing raus, die Geschwindigkeit.
Weil du bist gerade in diesem Flow von diesen Kämpfen, der sich wahnsinnig gut entwickelt.
Und dann kommt wieder diese Hüpf-Passage, oder diese Geschicklichkeits-Passage, wo man dann denkt so...
Na ja, warum muss ich jetzt hier fünfmal versuchen, diese Wand hoch zu klettern, wenn ich gerade vorher 100 Dämonen platt gemacht habe?
Das wirkt so ein bisschen aus dem Kontext gerissen vielleicht manchmal und fügt sich nicht so organisch ein, wie es die Entwickler vielleicht gern hätten.
Wird sicherlich neben dem inzwischen sehr bunten hat, der wahrscheinlich streitbarste Punkt in der Singleplayer-Kampagne werden.
Zum Abschluss mal, gib mal so eine Art Fazit, wie rund fühlt sich das an?
Also ist das ein tolles Spiel? Sind das eher die Sorgenpunkte, die die überwiegen?
Also für mich hat sich in den drei Städten...
Das ist kein... Ich glaube, das ist kein Spiel, was man gut streamen kann. Das ist langweilig zuzugucken.
Wahnsinnig rund angefühlt. Das war noch ein früher Bild. Das heißt, das war nicht die aktuellste Version, die es gab von dem Spiel.
Und trotzdem haben sich die Kämpfe mega gut gespielt. Ich bin direkt danach zu Hause noch mal in Doom 2016 reingesprungen,
dass ich als wahnsinnig flüssige in Erinnerung hatte und dachte, oh ist das langsam, da fehlt mir das alles.
Also sie haben da wirklich sinnvolle Mechaniken reingebaut.
Das Einzige, was mich ausbremst... Der Flammenwerfer... waren diese Jump-and-Run-Passagen. Da bleibt noch abzuwarten, wie häufig die vorkommen
oder ob es wirklich so ein Ding ist, was du halt hin und wieder mal machst, um vielleicht auch zu trainieren, besser zu werden in diesen Bewegungen, was dann wieder gut wäre.
Und der dritte Punkt war, dass mich die Festung, also dieses Hauptquartier und das, was man jetzt schon an mehr Story drin erlebt oder erleben kann,
hat mich auch schon recht gut abgeholt und gut mitgenommen, weil ich einfach jemand war, der in Doom 2016 auch gerne mal diese Codex-Einträge und die Log-Bücher gelesen hat.
Ich glaube, ich hab nicht eins gelesen in Doom 2016.
Die Entwickler haben mir auch im Gespräch gesagt, sie wollen wirklich die Doom-Lore größer machen in Eternal und das ist was, worauf ich mich auf jeden Fall freue.
Wer keine Lust drauf hat, kann das übrigens komplett skippen, alles.
Sollte man denn in Doom 2016...
Sollten wir es wieder erwarten, doch streamen. Ich werde keinerlei Audio-Logs und Log-Buchssachen lesen, das kann ich ja jetzt schon sagen.
In Erinnerung zu rufen, worum es da eigentlich geht oder kommt man da ganz gut rein?
Das geht mir auch bei Spielen wie, was weiß ich, bei Vier oder bei irgendwelchen Spielen, das ist aber voll auf den Keks,
wenn die dann wollen, dass man quasi eine halbe Stunde rumsteht und irgendwelche Log-Bücher liest und Audiobooks anhört.
Das war auch in BioShock teilweise ein bisschen übertrieben.
Das kommt darauf an, wie tief man einsteigen will.
Wenn man einfach nur die, ich sag jetzt mal, Oberflächen-Historie erleben will, dann reicht das vollkommen, einfach Doom Eternal anzuschmeißen.
Wenn du ein bisschen tiefer einsteigen willst und wirklich alle Referenzen auch verstehen willst,
dann würde ich empfehlen, nochmal vielleicht einen Durchlauf durch Doom 2016 zu machen
und dann nochmal die Log-Bücher und die Codex-Einträge zu lesen.
Eine letzte Frage, wenn schon alles irgendwie größer und umfangreicher wird.
Sie haben auch gesagt, dass die Kampagne doppelt so lang sein soll wie sein Vorgänger.
Ja, doppelt so lang. Müssen wir in der Vollversion natürlich erstmal überprüfen.
Das wäre gut. Aber sprechen wir noch kurz über Upgrade.
Die Kampagne von dem letzten Doom Warshow hatte schon eine ordentliche Länge, aber es war halt sehr repertiv irgendwie.
Das war schon am Ende. Vor allem diese Höllenwärfel waren alles das Gleiche.
Wenn sie das gut füllen, wäre nice.
Braids, das war ja bei Doom 2016 auch ein bisschen eine Überraschung, wie viel man an den Waffen auch rumbasteln konnte.
Wie sieht es da jetzt im neuen Teil aus?
Das ist sogar noch ein bisschen mehr geworden, ohne dass es sich für mich jetzt in dieser kurzen Anspielzeit überladen angefühlt hat.
Solange sie es nicht machen wie bei Dead Space 3, dass sie wollen, dass du Microtransactions kaufst.
Das heißt, du hast wieder verschiedene Upgrades oder verschiedene Versionen von Waffen.
Du kannst jetzt zum Beispiel die Shotgun, eine Gatling-Gun umbauen und alles Mögliche.
Und diese Mods dann wiederum upgraden durch Challenges.
Dann hast du wieder die Rüstung, die sich upgraden lässt.
Die hat jetzt auch verschiedene Modi für Granaten, zum Beispiel kannst du statt Sprenggranaten so Frostgranaten verschießen, die dann Gegner einfrieren.
Und dann hast du noch Runen-Upgrades, also spezielle Perks, die du freischalten kannst.
Und das ergibt dann alles in allem zwar kein RPG-artiges System, aber doch was, wo ein bisschen Tiefe drinsteckt.
Es kommt heute kein Game mehr aus ohne Skill-Bomb. Geht nicht.
Mit verschiedenen Waffen-Konfigurationen und so.
Klingt auf jeden Fall, wie ich finde, immer noch sehr, sehr spannend.
Aber das gucke ich mir auf jeden Fall an.
Das sind diese ganzen Jump-and-Run-Elemente, wie gut sich die am Ende in das fertige Spiel einbauen.
Wir werden es erfahren spätestens am, was hatte ich gesagt, 20. März kommt es raus für PC, PS4, Xbox One.
Und kommt es da eigentlich auch gleich für die Switch.
Für die Switch kommt es ein bisschen später raus.
Wer es vorbestellt, kriegt das Game 64.
Das ist jetzt erstmals für PC, Xbox One, Switch.
Ja, das habe ich gebraucht jetzt noch mal.
Wir freuen uns auf jeden Fall sehr auf die Testversion.
Und haben dann hoffentlich zum Release auch bildlich ein Testvideo für euch.
Mit der finalen Einschätzung zu Doom Eternal.
Vielen Dank fürs Zusehen.
Sehr gerne.
Euch vielen Dank fürs Zuschauen. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
CU!
So, was haben wir sonst noch hier?
Hm.
Komm, wir gucken uns doch fast immer traditionell am Ende noch eine Battlefield-Top-Plays an.
Du hast das Battlefield-Video? Okay, gucken wir uns an.
Dann bin ich schon schon on.
Drei Stunden! Ich muss mal dringend aufs Klo, aber das gucken wir noch.
So, ich habe letztendlich auf Battlefield 5 gespielt.
Es gibt viele Gründe dafür, aber um eine lange Geschichte kurz zu schneiden,
genieße ich einfach nicht mehr das Spiel.
500 Stunden in...
Oh, so lange hätte ich dem Leben dadurch gehalten.
...hat genug.
Bugs, Glitches, schreckliche Server, wahre Balance
und natürlich das unnötige TTK 5.2-Update.
Ich habe genug gehabt und bin jetzt am Ende der Zeit.
Und ich werde jetzt warten, um DICE zu verhindern,
und dann vielleicht wieder ein bisschen spielen.
Bis dann aber ist es zurück zu Battlefield 3 und 4
und vielleicht noch ein bisschen Battlefield 1,
unter anderem anderen Spielen.
Die Gameplay, die ihr in der Hintergrund seht,
ist von vor dem TTK-Change, dann ein bisschen von BF1 und...
Was ist das? Was haben sie denn gemacht?
Ich weiß, sie haben was an der Time-2-Kill gedreht.
Und angeblich würden Gegner jetzt irgendwie
fünf Magazine aushalten oder so.
Ist das wirklich so extrem?
Ich weiß, was ist mit denen...
Warum sollte man das machen?
Die haben doch da irgendeinen Hintergedanken bestimmt gehabt, oder?
Die haben von Battlefield 4 gedreht.
Das ist einer der größten Gründe, warum ich das Spiel gedreht habe.
Ich bin nicht allein mit dieser Entscheidung.
Viele andere Kreatoren und Spieler
haben den Ende ihrer Zeit mit Battlefield 5 erreicht.
Es scheint ein guter Zeitpunkt, andere Spiele zu schauen,
vielleicht sogar Call of Duty Modern Warfare,
bis DICE ihre Aktion zusammen machen können.
Ich werde bald auf Videos von diesem Spiel schauen.
Ich werde es ein bisschen spielen und sehen,
ob ich etwas von Battlefield-Spielern ausbauen kann.
In meiner Sparzeit genieße ich auch andere Spiele.
Ich lehne mich nicht nur an die Battlefield-Franchise,
aber das ist das Hauptspiel, das ich gerne spiele, Battlefield.
Ich komme online mit meinen Freunden und es ist ein guter Lach.
Letztendlich habe ich in der Sparzeit nicht viel Spaß gemacht.
Ich bin derjenige, der nicht viel Spaß macht.
Ich werde es nicht spielen,
auch wenn ich auf YouTube-Videos spiele.
Die Top-Player werden weitergehen.
Natürlich werde ich ein Battlefield-Video machen,
aber ich werde die älteren Titel in den nächsten Videos wiederholen.
In diesem Video werde ich die Laundry-Liste schauen,
die ein bisschen von Battlefield 5 gedreht werden muss.
Ja, dann mach mal.
Dann erzähl uns mal, warum es sagt.
Battlefield 5 sieht auf einmal aber ganz schön anders aus.
So modern.
Das ist die übelste Crap-Map gewesen in Battlefield 4.
Die Satellitenschüsse.
Also ich gehe jetzt von Rush.
Huge Spawn.
Was? Slaver? Saver?
Nein, aber ich würde gerne,
und ich muss mich damit unbedingt beschäftigen,
weil die Kohle wird weniger,
wenn sie einfach nur sinnlos rumliegt.
Huge NA1.
Echt? War das ein Patch, um die Weihnachtsnoobs zu beschützen?
Es hat nicht ein Update Battlefield gekillt, das stimmt.
DICE hat das mit den letzten zwei Games für mich gekillt.
Ich denke, wir sind alle ziemlich gut,
mit Bugs in Battlefield-Games zu kämpfen,
die den Frostbite-Engine benutzen.
Die größten Probleme mit Battlefield-
Am besten sind immer noch die Battlefield 4,
die LRV-Physics, wo man den LRV
über die ganze Map jumpen lassen kann.
Five though, have been here since launch,
and I can't really say things have improved much
since that initial week.
There's no real sign of them being resolved either.
Man würde ja eigentlich denken, ne?
Also ein normal denkender Mensch würde vermuten,
dass Battlefield 4 und Battlefield 5 spricht.
Dass das zwei Games sind,
die nacheinander rausgekommen sind.
Ist aber nicht so.
Dazwischen war Battlefield Hardline und Battlefield 1
und dann Battlefield 5.
DICE seem to fix something
and then break something else.
There's something definitely wrong
with the way that they do things.
I'm not going to say I know better.
I certainly don't. I'm not a dev.
That's not what I do for my main job.
I work in something completely separate from gaming.
Looking at Battlefield 5,
I can't say that I'm impressed with it whatsoever.
There's been no real improvement
if you take the last 14 months as an example.
Poor performance across all platforms.
I still get huge stutters,
as you lot well know.
It started with the Apocalypse DLC and BF1
and it's just been in Battlefield since then.
I've done absolutely everything you can do
to try and fix it.
I bought a new PC, reinstalled Windows
and I still get stutters in both those games.
I do have ways of working around it
with a few programs that do certain things
to prevent memory buildup and CPU spiking,
but it's still there.
Ja, okay, das liegt wahrscheinlich einfach in seinem PC.
Weil insgesamt muss man sagen,
Battlefield läuft, finde ich,
immer ziemlich gut.
Performance-mäßig, wohlgemerkt.
Bugs ist was anderes.
Performance-mäßig konnte man sich
bei den letzten zwei Battlefield-Teilen
nicht beschweren.
Und davor eigentlich auch nicht.
It's off the scale once again
for some players in virtually every other game.
Some people encounter them more than others.
I get that and some regions definitely have
larger issues than other regions.
But they are in the game.
There is no denying it.
When I report a cheater, is it actually doing something?
Ja, wahrscheinlich nicht.
But I see players cheating
from level 10, 15 all the way up
to 50 and beyond.
Die haben überhaupt kein Interesse dran, die Leute zu bannen.
Hahaha, BTF!
Was?
Was geht mir denn ab?
Ich glaube, bei DICE ist es überhaupt
noch nicht eingekommen, dass Leute die Spiele
streamen. Dementsprechend
ist auch das
zu erkennen. Selbst wenn
Battlefield neu ist und wenn
Battlefield an sich viele Spieler hat,
gestreamt wird das Game so gut wie nicht.
Warum ist Escape from Tarkov eigentlich
gerade so angesagt? Das ist doch schon
uralt. Das habe ich nicht
kapiert.
Rewards durchzugucken, okay?
Das ist eigentlich
Big Brain, ey. Das müsste
ich auch machen. Das müsste
ich auch machen. Es gibt Rewards durchzugucken.
Also jetzt nicht irgendwie,
da muss ich mir irgendwas Sinnloses ausdenken
und dann ist da
ein huge Zuschauer
Increase.
Ich wurde so oft gekickt
schon in Battlefield 3 und teilweise
4, aber Battlefield 3 habe ich richtig viel gespielt.
So oft gekickt, weil ihm irgendwas nicht
gefallen hat, was ich gemacht habe.
Von Cheater bist du
angeblich falsche Waffe gespielt
und sonst was.
Es war nur der Name frei.
Meinst du, warum ich das
anstehen habe?
Ich will Loops
baschen. Sowohl in God als auch in Battlefield.
Baschen, Alter, den ganzen Tag.
Bam.
Einfach ein Team machen mit vier guten
Leuten und alles zerstören. Das finde ich
in Battlefield so.
Hab das gehört.
Ja, jung, mittlerweile ist das tatsächlich so.
Trotz Kappa.
Mittlerweile ist das so. Ich habe ewig kein
Battlefield mehr gespielt.
Aber es ist erstaunlich,
wenn man die Spiele mal eine Weile gesuchtet hat,
so wie ich, wie schnell man wieder reinkommt,
wenn man mal wieder anfängt.
Ist das hier jetzt eigentlich Battlefield 5
oder 1, was man da gerade sieht?
Das ist die Beta Map aus 5, ne?
Deswegen verwirrt mich das so.
Das ist die Beta Map aus 5.
Das verstehe ich auch nicht. Ja, Map Voting.
Leider kann man auch keine ordentliche
Custom Server mal machen. Es war richtig cool,
dass man in Battlefield 3, Bad Company und
teilweise auch noch in Battlefield 4, das hatte
ich auf meinem Server damals ja auch drauf.
Wir hatten ein Sniper-Limit. Einfach, dass sich
ein Rush was bewegt.
Es war für beide Seiten nämlich nicht geil,
wenn drei Viertel der Teams
rumgeschneibert hatten. Wir hatten glaube ich
zwei oder drei, vier vielleicht
Sniper-Slots pro Team.
Und das lief richtig gut.
Gibt es bei einem Server noch eine?
Ne, ne, ich fahre eigentlich nicht mehr.
Das hat er gut gespielt.
Dieses komische Bauen ist auch
kompletter Nuss.
Der Minecraft-Zug ist allweil geil.
Man kann die
Messe nicht mit den ersten Maps bekommen.
Man will nur Pläne auf Maps haben, aber
einfach nur den Loadout limitieren.
Eine Pläne, die ein bestimmtes Loadout
mit Air Vehicle, Tanks und Infanterie
gut gegen sich bringt,
eine Art Mixer von allen.
Nicht ein Skill-Tree, der
Spieler die ultimative 0 für
Infanterie holen kann.
Ich habe Videos gemacht, es ist so einfach,
100 für 0 in einer Pläne wie der
braucht sehr wenig Skill.
Und es ist frustrierend.
ids
Das war jetzt
Wow
Nice
Sind das die
Vornamen hoo asked
Er so 100 Kills Null
Es war so 100 Kills Null
Als Gunner
Wobei ne, war Chopper Gunner aus MW2
Battlefield Driver
Nachladen
Oh huge
Skill, Soundskills
Also, wenn du in deinen Spielen weniger Schnauze, weniger Frustration und weniger Leute quittest, weil es scheiße ist, ist das sicher etwas, das du schauen musst.
Flugzeuge sind immer noch auf Fjell geflogen, non-stop, sechs Flugzeuge pro Team.
Das ist nicht eine lustige Erfahrung für Fußballspieler.
Es macht alles auch noch schlimmer, wenn es um Flugzeuge geht.
Und die Tanks in den Spielen, so wie alle in Battlefield V sind,
in BF4
Die Tanks in den Spielen, das macht alles auch noch schlimmer, wenn es um Flugzeuge geht.
Und die Tanks in den Spielen, so wie alle in Battlefield V sind,
in BF4 waren Flugzeuge überall.
Sie fahrten alle, auch in BF3.
Aber du hörst die Leute nicht zu viel über die Tanks.
Und das ist, weil Flugzeuge auch Flagge mitgebracht haben.
Sie haben Objekte mitgebracht.
Sie haben den Team vorgebracht.
K.D. in Flugzeuge ist massiv.
Verstehe mich nicht.
Es ist sehr, sehr wichtig.
Aber gleichzeitig muss man den Team vorgehen,
das Objekt aufnehmen,
die Tanks kapieren und das Balance finden.
Das ist auch ein Panzer.
Das ging aber halt in Battlefield alles,
nur wenn die Gegner auch reingeschossen haben.
Battlefield V
Wie du siehst aus der Battlefield IV-Gameplay,
in der Hintergrund, die ich in diesem Video geschaut habe,
bekommen wir viele Töne in Fahrzeugen.
Mein Team und ich werden herumgehen,
eine Flagge kapieren,
eine Tank töten, ein Flugzeug töten, ein paar Spieler töten,
meine Töne bekommen ein paar Töne,
wir arbeiten zusammen,
und es sieht so aus, als wäre es eine schmutzige Operation.
Aber gleichzeitig
bekomme ich wahrscheinlich eine bessere Töne als in BFV.
Die Fahrzeuge bieten sich einfach
zu diesem spannenden,
schnellen Gameplay.
In Battlefield V sitze ich einfach auf einer Hölle und schiebe Sachen.
Natürlich kann ich das Objekt von Zeit zu Zeit aus drücken,
aber es ist nicht wirklich wert.
Es ist nicht wert, die Risiken zu haben, also sitze ich auf einer Hölle und töte Leute.
Das ist das, warum die meisten meiner Freunde
Battlefield V nie erzielt haben,
dass die Fahrzeuge es nicht beinhalten wollen.
Warum beinhalten Sie sich,
wenn Sie einfach BFV spielen können?
Es verbindet sich mit dem TTK,
aber es ist ein ganz anderes Anglein,
der Wappen-Balanz in Battlefield V.
Vor dem TTK-Update
war die Wappen-Balanz ziemlich gut.
Ich denke, jeder Wappen hatte eine Nische.
Man konnte etwas mit einigen Wappen machen,
andere Wappen würden besser sein,
und man musste den Loadout gewinnen.
Es waren ein paar Meta-Panzer,
die ich immer benutzt habe.
Die MG war großartig, ich glaube nicht,
dass es die beste Wappen in der Assault-Klasse war.
Siehst du, wo ich herkomme.
Es waren nicht so viele God-Wappen,
ein paar, aber es war nicht so schlimm.
Jetzt ist es sehr klar,
was die besten Wappen sind.
Die 2A mit der 50-Round Mag.
Es ist verrückt.
Ein paar andere Wappen, die man benutzen kann.
Ich denke, die STG ist eigentlich sehr gut.
In der Support-Klasse
runnst du immer noch Schusswaffen
in CQB,
und wenn du noch etwas anderes hast,
kannst du vielleicht mit einem K7
oder einem Rampor...
Am coolsten mit dem Panzer-Fun fand ich
am Anfang in Battlefield 3,
wo man noch...
Oder ich bin mir gar nicht sicher,
ob ich das jetzt nicht mit Battlefield 4 verwechsel.
Wo man noch...
Primary, Fire und...
Wie hieß es?
Diese Shotgun für den Panzer.
Die Dings...
Canister Shell.
Die ging ja auch komplett über die ganze Map.
Du konntest...
Du hast sie so zerrissen.
Du konntest mit Canister Shell
quer über die ganze Map Leute
wegknallen.
Und du konntest doppelt, doppelt schießen.
Das war so richtig nice.
Richtig krass.
Wenn du da noch einen kompetenten
MG-Gunner hattest, war einfach huge.
Ich kann mich da noch
erinnern, wo man
auf hier Strikart Karkan
mit dem Panzer...
Warte mal, war das Strikart Karkan?
Oder gab es ein LRW irgendwo? Du konntest
so geil die Häuser in die Luft sprengen
und danach mit der Canister Shell
die Leute rausbashing.
Das war richtig nice.
Ich glaube, es war Battlefield 3.
Es kann durchaus sein, dass es in Battlefield 4 auch ging.
Aber es war am Anfang Battlefield 3.
Du hast wirklich Primary, Fire und danach
gleich Canister Shell.
Das war Tank Zones.
Das war geil.
Aber das ist jetzt Battlefield 1, oder?
Leute, das ist jetzt Battlefield 1.
Oder?
Das sieht sich so ähnlich
alles mittlerweile.
Ich will
bashen.
Es ist mir egal, ob ich mit niedriger oder
hoher Time to Kill bashe.
Aber es sollte nicht das komplette,
den kompletten Geist des Games ändern.
Das wissen sie wahrscheinlich selber nicht.
He he.
Ja.
Richtig.
Was willst du sonst spielen?
Stimmt.
Was eigentlich mit Firestorm?
Spielt das überhaupt noch jemand?
Neues Alter, IW.
Heißt jetzt ja anders.
Ja, das gibt's noch.
Das heißt bloß anders.
Jaja, das gibt's noch.
Das heißt nicht anders.
Ja, gäbe ich ihm recht.
Obwohl ich das Spiel nicht gespielt habe.
Hey Leute und willkommen
zu einem Stück von Battlefield 4.
In diesem Video werde ich
in dem Angriffshelikopter spielen.
Ich...
Interessiert mich auch nicht so großartig.
Leute, ich muss übelst...
Ich hab Hunger.
Und ich muss aufs Klo.
Und ich bin 3, 3 Stunden 30
am Start gewesen.
Vielleicht, aber nur vielleicht.
Und ihr kennt mich, wenn ich vielleicht sage,
ist es eher nicht.
Spiel heute Abend halten voll fertig.
Dauert ja nicht mehr lang, noch 3 Stunden oder so.
2,5 Stunden oder so.
Mal gucken.
Aber wie gesagt, verlasst euch nicht drauf,
wenn ich so Zeug ich erzähle.
Dann ist es nämlich ja meistens nicht so.
Wieder war es wunderbar, dass so viele Leute dabei waren.
Danke für die ganzen Subs.
Ich geh jetzt was essen.
Und aufs Klo.
Wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream.
Bis dann. See you.